what up guys welcome to the just parate
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame out of Miami everyone
[Applause]
class um before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and also guys
make sure you go subscribe to our two
clips channels and our new Talent at the
audacity Network Christine also guys if
you want to apply to be part of the
audacity Network and you live in London
shot me a message as we are assigning
Talent now okay so today we have taken
on Miami so to start why don't we go
around everyone say your name age
relationship status and what you do for
a living starting here and then going
around my my name is fonnie I'm 21 years
old I am single and I do
sales what do you sell plastic surgery
oh shout out to Miami my name is name is
Eric I'm 35 and I am a YouTuber we have
a podcast shout out to my boy right
there that's my co-host unfilter podcast
and what was the other question what do
I sell age relationship status uh I'm
taken and uh yes I'm a YouTuber so there
you
go hi my name is chrisy I'm 29 years old
I'm a real estate agent in the State of
Florida I have a pet care business
called a pet home away from home check
it out I serve West Palm to Miami I have
a vending machine business if you need
any vending machines I got you right now
I have a an all Drink Machine available
and a drink and snack machine available
right now and then I also do an online
retail store so I basically buy and flip
anything I can get my hands on ni lots
of
businesses no
boyfriend I I was engaged for six years
together for eight and um I've been
single on purpose for the past two years
what what happened to him he seems like
a great guy eight years um he was a
great guy um but I actually found out
that um he was bisexual and I did not
like that so I left so so would that be
her fault then by your logic because
everything's your fault right so yeah
you know there's probably sign yeah
yeah no no no no no he's actually really
like that's what I how how did you find
out he bisexual um I actually my phone
broke and my accountant called me for a
pen to cuz he was doing my taxes and I
had to go into my email and asked him to
borrow his phone and when I went to his
phone um I went to go to my email he had
a Gmail I had Yahoo I went to Yahoo
there was already an email in there and
I just signed in and it was like welcome
to kick your friends are messaging you
on Kick and then I looked at the videos
and saw what he was saying and it was
just it was mad it was Madness yeah but
can I see a picture of them I want to
see what I want to see if I could if I
my gar goes on okay okay okay go ahead
hi guys I'm Rebecca Jay I am 30 I live
in Miami I have a transportation cup
compy Miami I am an only fans model I
also have a film company here as well
for 29 filmous if you want to follow me
on social media is Rebecca J
live hi I'm Ashley I'm 26 I'm a
financial strategist and I'm in a
relationship beautiful Troy Francis 49 I
am a dating coach YouTuber content
creator all that good stuff dedicated
Bachelor completely single no women in
my life no women St in my hotel at the
moment at all and um hi Tiff and uh yeah
uh if you want to follow me on social
media real try Francis on uh YouTube uh
Twitter and
Instagram I'm Hector I'm 30 years old
I'm in a very serious relationship with
a very beautiful woman and what else
name age relationship status and fun
fact oh fun fact oh wait what you do for
a living what I do for a living so I am
one of the host on the realist of
podcast in Miami unfiltered podcast and
I help men unlock the ultimate versions
of themselves and master high
status so today I want to learn about
what is dating like in Miami great yes
yes wow there's no gar actually going
off you might you mind I'm I'm going to
give this to you very she turned him
gay she turned him gay think about that
such a bad girlfriend that your
boyfriend went gay what you he by so
he's yeah he likes both yeah does that
happen no there's no such thing as
bisexual men you're homosexual no if you
like men does he look show him does he
look gay to you he doesn't look gay to
me yes really what what gives it away
what is it let
me he doesn't talk let me
see yes yes I'm I'm telling you look at
his look come Jesus that looks that
looks free that looks free to okay
see see I said the same thing do you see
how see all the all the men all the men
could point it out so I guess this is
why you asked the guys the way we would
look at it is I wouldn't hang around
that dude yeah I wouldn't hang out with
him no I wouldn't hang around him just
the way he look yeah you would I'm
telling you that person because you
already gave it away that's why that's
the only reason why well I mean I have
three dudes I hang with I don't really
hang around dudes anyway so yeah men
know my circle's really small but yeah
he he gives me the the beautiful man I
just could I probably probably too
beautiful wow you think he's too
beautiful when a guy's like too good
looking you think he's too beautiful oh
yeah when a guy's like too good-look M
they're gay yeah but he wasn't that's
what like it wasn't he wasn't perfect
how does it feel how does it feel that
like us women are doing so bad that the
men are turning to other men to be women
better than than man that's it s it
been turning men have been uh doing this
for forever yeah now they're just now
it's just more open because it's
accepted like that's why they're doing
it more open it's accepted by women it's
accepted by no men don't accept
homosexuality but let's not forget that
women are going turning into men because
women are more masculine than ever
nowadays in the West in the west you're
pointing at her but you got to he's
making a good point okay but why why why
are wom more masculine yeah why why
they've been tricked by what's going on
in society with everything that's going
on it's tricked no they've been put in
the position oh in the feminist movement
but yeah I can go on and on all night
for that okay I would argue it's because
um women have just decided to be men and
we suck at being
men yeah I don't think it's about us
deciding to be men I think that we have
literally been put in a position because
men used to stick around men used to
take care of the household no women
leave overwhelmingly now now because
they they're not in a position to where
they need so now already already it's
men's fault we're only like 2 minutes in
and it's men's fault already men's fault
well the men the men the men aren't
hanging around in the home though
because you guys started leaving like in
the 70s you started didn't well no we
didn't we didn't we didn't most divor
most divorces are initiated by
women in this day and age but men
started creating single moms back in the
80s 90s where men started leaving
relationships of what percent of men
create single mothers I don't like have
multiple baby mothers I'm not sure I
don't know it's funny it's funny that
it's men's fault it's funny that it's if
if it's men's fault it's because it's
under men's control so at the end
exactly so at the end of the day you
still need men for it to be their fault
that's what you don't understand you
don't need men to for it to be their
fault it's your fault because you guys
are leaving the home you guys are
creating you guys creating and if you
don't need if you don't need men women
are the ones leaving men aren't leaving
they're leaving they in a position where
they can her argument her argument is
that the reason a woman had to stick
around in order to live the life that
she wanted to live because like she
couldn't work that's not necessarily
true like there was um there was still
instances of divorce even before the 60s
I know but not as much as now because
now we're in a better position there's
there's writing no there's writings from
writing from the 1800s of women like of
men complaining about divorce court it
was just more culturally shamed honestly
and women tend to go with like what the
culture does well it's like it's not it
was really like imposed by Society the
culture religion and everything back
then wasn't it have slowly eroded over
time and now it's kind of a freefor all
so now we're in Miami and everyone's
just partying [__] each other and you
know we're in this kind of cardi B world
now that we all inhabit basically but no
women are the ones leaving so I so I
think it's women's fault it's not
women's I don't I I also don't think I
also I would imagine I mean we'd have to
check the stats of this but I I I can't
see that it was always men leaving back
then and now it's suddenly majority
women I think it was probably women who
were getting dissatisfied in marriages
even back then I I think it's both but
I'm saying a lot of men were not
stepping up to be fathers that's why we
have so many women that are single
mothers cuz men are quick to leave
that's not true women are women are they
get no they what is making the men leave
like they're just walking out they just
wake up one day and say hey I'm going to
leave or is the women it's the fact that
they have too many opportunities there's
so many options only only only 10% of
men report having more than one sexual
partner in a year and you believe that
yeah that's what I was going to say that
so even even even if you even if you
even if you double it that's still only
30% 30% of men um have said that at some
point in their lives they they've had
multiple sexual partners in a year but
only 10% in a given year will say
they've had multiple sexual partners
that was done that was that that was
surveyed um in the past year and it was
over 5,000 men so it was a relatively
large sample side it was the United
States yeah yeah see like I'm talking
about like here in Miami like in Florida
in Florida people don't guys leave
there's too many options they don't
stick
around but saying that's like only what
percent of men even father multiple kids
a lot most of them you no no it's like
15% of men it's because again you guys
are all swiping you're all dating the
same guys so that's why so it's like if
you want a guy that's six foot what
percent of men is that 15% if you want a
guy that makes six figures what percent
of men is that 10% you want a guy that's
good-look what percent of men is that
you only find 20% of men attractive so a
guy that's got all three that's five
three two% mhm so so that's my point
like but doesn't take fact that men are
leaving that men again you're looking at
this you're looking at this through the
you're looking at this through the Miami
filter again though because you're
saying oh men have got these
opportunities and they're going to leave
because theyve got these opportunities
that is really the very very top
percentile of men I mean like
5% probably less than 5% of dudes have
those opportunities a lot of those guys
probably do live in Miami or maybe they
live in LA or New York or whatever but
the vast majority of men are invisible
to women so the vast majority of normal
dudes they don't have all these multiple
opportunities that they think you do but
you guys don't see those men because
you're not you know you they're barely
visible to you because that you're not
attracted to them you don't think
they're cool so it's not the case for
most guys no I'm saying back in the um
1980s 1990s men the the family Dynamic
changed men started men started cheating
a lot more they started not even being
they get women pregnant what evidence do
you have of that it's just it's just
facts no no but where where I just want
it's just facts it's just facts like
everyone knows that like Tupac even like
wrote it mentioned in one of his songs
Tupac yeah
Tupac Tupac Tupac heyat Tupac died Tupac
died at 25 his brain wasn't even fully
developed as a man Tupac was young
Reckless and dumb that's why he got
killed and you're basing your facts off
of Tupac no I'm just saying he made a
statement about it when because he was
back in that time talking about the 80s
and 90s um uh we're having a race of
babies that I'll hate the ladies or
something like that that's you're
quoting a rap lyric because back then
the family damic miss the family Dynamic
was already disintegrating back then
it's only gotten worse over time that's
what I'm saying you you know here's the
problem though I'm gonna I'm going to
tell you something all of this stuff is
just painting a picture to lie to you
and to make to to create a gender war
and make us think that men are the
problem really we're the problem so they
they make millions and millions of
dollars off us leaving this
[__] like it's
not fair I've tried to save her for the
last few months she's unsavable I
promise you bro she's unsavable even
even if we go based off of facts right
again this was a 2023 study or it's
either 2023 or 2022 so relatively new
and they they surveyed 5,000 men only
10% of men report having multiple sexual
partners in a
yearh so it's only 10% of men that are
sleeping around like that no it's most
men no it's not she's telling you the
fact she's telling you a fact fact that
she researched she took the time to
research and you
don't and said that just said
it okay I'll tell you I'll tell you how
we know it's a fact because you you use
multiple data sources so then you back
that up with dating app stats where 5%
of men get most of the swipes that that
backs up what the men are also saying
then you find other other surveys that
say the same thing in different areas
it's roughly 10% maybe some you'll find
15 maybe we'll even go crazy and say
it's 20 can we Circle back real quick on
when you said that most women are the
ones that are leaving the relationship
is not men MH do you have an answer as
to why why do you think women are
choosing to leave relationship because
they get bored and they want to
something else they want the shiny shiny
bright thing hypergamy that
isil hypergamy wait wait actually I want
I want her to say that go say that on
the mic yeah yeah so why do why do you
think why do you think women are leaving
the reason why I think women are leaving
is because back then women were put in a
position to where well men had set the
life up to where they had more power
women needed a man to live the life or
provide the life that she wanted now
that women can provide the life that
they want they don't have to stick
around when a man is being disloyal
disloyal to you he's not being honest
he's in and out of the house and living
life on his own accord while also trying
so so your your impression is that 50%
50% of marriages fail right and on top
of that if we included long-term
relationships most fail to do you know
the statistics for how long
relationships last so it it depends if
it's if you don't if you get married
it's like seven eight years if you're in
just a normal relationship it's roughly
three okay okay so so and your
impression is that they are just
disloyal men that are are failing well
no I think it's just men before women
were put in a position to where they
needed a man more now we're not in a
position where we need it as much so
we're so we're quicker to leave because
we don't need them as much no no so so
your first the first point is true
because yes economically you don't need
men because you can women work and
obviously there's government support and
all that so that's absolutely true the
bit that I contest is the reason why
they're leaving so Paul was on a show
and this anecdotal Paul was on a show
recently on in in the UK and a woman on
there was saying that there was this
woman who was she was in her 60s they've
been married for 20 years they had
several kids together and then in her
60s this woman decided to leave the
husband and the reason she gave was well
I've I've been like constrained I've
only been a wife and a mother all of my
life I want to explore myself I want to
explore myself as being a different kind
of woman that guy as far as we know
wasn't disloyal that guy wasn't [__]
around you know it was just she was like
oh the grass is green or I want to do
the E pray love thing so I think you
know my impression is that a lot of
women are leaving because they kind of
get bored in the grass is greener on the
other side I think that applies in some
situations for sure but I think in most
situations when a woman is in a
relationship with a man and she chooses
to leave that man the man has let her
down in some way and she and she's
decided that she and she's decided it's
better without what has let me down it's
relationships people let you down all
the time I I will say this and this is
you like my thing is you've never let
someone down ever really are you God I
never let my partner down never really
like this is narcissism come on like
never you've been a perfect angel no
you've been a perfect stigma um do you
know the personality trits the like the
I don't care I'm asking okay you were
perfect in your relationship yes no she
was she was so that's the issue that's
the issue with women today that's the
issue with the majority of women today
is the lack of accountability so you're
telling me I always hold myself you did
nothing wrong in any relationship no
I've only been in one relationship from
19 to 27 and I did nothing wrong nothing
wrong nothing wrong I got the ring I
would want to ask I got the ring I'm the
one who chose to leave call him right
now call him right now oh okay okay all
right all right yeah yeah oh oh yeah oh
yeah I would say this I I feel like
people in general give up on each other
way too quickly and when you going into
a marriage if you decide this is the
person that I'm going to marry then you
do have to see it through as much as you
can right and this is why people in the
60s and the 70s that did last long
marriages they always say the same thing
you don't you don't give up on the
person that you're with you just you
know you just fix it you fix your
problems nowadays because there's so
many options and because because there's
so many places you can go to get what
you need it's like that uh 2080 rule we
don't have to settle do you know what
the 2080 rule is what isle yeah what the
[__] what are you talk need you I want
heard her finish what she's saying and
then I'll say it so the 2080 rule is
when you're with somebody they're giving
you 80% because really no one is perfect
and then you go out and you meet someone
with the you you meet someone and you
think oh they're feeling that 20% void
that the person you're with isn't fing
because and so but it goes both ways
it's not just the woman it it's it's on
both sides it's on both sides this why
women should not give advice bro the
only difference the only this why women
need fathers I'm not first of all number
one I'm not saying that I agree with
that I think that people need to work
things out for as much unless you're
being you know mistreated to the point
where he's beating your ass he's
cheating so much that he's bringing
diseases back home to you he's
mistreating your kids and the kid just
any of those things that are obvious to
everybody like that's wrong but stupid
[__] like fighting every day he didn't
clean the dishes or he didn't help me
with the trash or he's like those things
can be worked through and I feel like
nowadays yeah I mean people in general
not the SE what about if the sexism is
good because look we all know after a
few years the sex starts to you know you
know each other well the sex starts to
kind of you the men usually are the ones
to beer off first not necessarily cuz
women get bored as well cuz that women
will say well no I deserve to be
satisfied I deserve to have some f fun
fact actually fun fact if a guy has a
kid 5% chance it's not yours fellas yeah
Dr David Baker if anyone wants to Source
usually a man steps out for sex he wants
the reason why so does a woman I just
gave you 5% 5% chance she she'll only
listen to the facts that applied
to yeah it's not yours 5% uh chance and
it's that's on the low end actually some
people that have estimated it higher but
I think a lot of y'all opinions are
based off of just simple bad experiences
with
men expence wasn't really that bad it
seem it seems it seems as if you've only
you've only been with one man your whole
life oh I had eight sexual partners I've
only been in a relationship with one man
man ter life that's a red flag yeah
that's crazy you've had eight sexual
partners but you've only been in a
relationship with one of them yes 17 to
21 um my first two boy I had two before
him he was number three and then
everyone else has came after in the last
two years but you've only been in
relationship with eight of the men that
you with one of the eight men that you
let enter your body yes you don't you
don't see anything wrong with that no I
don't interesting um oh actually no my
first boyfriend we were together for
three years but I don't really consider
him an actual boyfriend cuz we were in
high school I'm saying as an adult as an
adult I've only dated 19 and 27 I've
dated one man but you had sex with him
in high school um my first my first
boyfriend yes After High School 18 I
think that you guys are basing your
opinions on just bad experiences with
men because if you were to have good
experiences with men experence only I'm
not saying him specifically I'm saying
with men in general okay yeah right not
him specifically you might have had a
very beautiful experience with I did I
really did I really can't say much but
then you said he was bisexual and that's
why you left that's literally the only
thing
ex AKA bad
experience do you think he was by
bisexual cuz I don't think a guy can be
bisexual can be B you think he was
bisexual I'm sorry do you think he was
gay before or after you yes I I know for
a fact he was gay before me because um
after I found the text messages I went
through the house and I found a list he
literally wrote a list of everybody
everybody he's ever slept with and there
was there was a guy's name on there
before me his name was Lando he have a
list wow and I don't think you could
just like Auto one from one day to the
next be like Oh I'm gay yeah no he was
before me I think and like actually um
you said how there might have been one
red flag the only red flag that I can
think of now after the fact is like when
we first started dating he talked a lot
about the his very best friend in middle
school and honestly he never said
anything it wasn't confirmed but I think
that was like his first love I think
that was the first person he was in love
with was his best friend in elementary
middle school I think he might have been
gay and then after dating you he was
like you know what I'm going to stick
with men
oh let's be serious Eric but no um and
also I think a big reason why he was
hiding who he was is because his dad is
homophobic and his and he my ex was 13
years my senior and his dad is very
homophobic so with having a homophobic
father what is homophobic like he he
doesn't they he they talk [__] they do
not like fat people they don't they
don't like it or they just don't accept
it or they disagree with it um no they
didn't like it they disagree with it
everything like it was like they
literally would you know what phobia
means yeah you're the fear of no
stronger rational fear I don't
understand it cuz if I don't like the
gay
stuff why why am I afraid of it I'm not
afraid of it I just don't I I don't like
it yeah no no his dad is homophobic he
literally are so he has a strong
rational you're missing what she saying
like I just I don't think that's like if
you don't support gay marriage or any of
that stuff why is it
homophobic I guess that's what that's
what everyone's just labeled it yeah
makes it seem like we're make the word
up Y no but I yeah know but I'm just
saying words are important so that
implies that like I'm afraid of it yeah
yeah and that proves my point that we
set off a air where said his mouth I'm
scared of gay people he said he he know
he this man went to war he wasn't scared
of anybody I'm afraid of gay he wasn't
scared of anybody but he had an
irrational fear against gay people
because that's what the word that people
use to do so just because they use it to
be fair I think the definition of the
term has been extended somewhat
popularly now like colloquially yes the
original the original definition you
from the Greek was fear of or irrational
you know strong irrational fear of
however I think the definition is now
been extended so people are using it to
label just just just general dislike
yeah yeah exactly but then that's not
homophobic you just don't like it so but
no I'm saying no but I'm say the the
manner the manner in which people are
now using the term has been extended
yeah they're just using it wrong you can
say you you can say
they literally a gay couple would be
walking by on the street and he would
like there's literally no no reason for
him to say anything and he would say oh
look at these [__] [__] you know I
love that
though I love that people should be able
to live their life free of other
people's judgment unless unless it's you
and affecting you like if I was if I was
a [__] and an only fans girl and you're
trying to get to know me and you like
it's affecting our children though it's
affecting our children then you can
place judgment if you if it comes into
you and it's cont you but everybody
judges
everybody I have to see it
everybody know I want like this I want
to well sometimes I will if I see it in
public God no but I don't why do we have
to like cater to them I don't I didn't
say not saying cater why you feel like
anyone has to cater to your beliefs and
well they they don't because I don't
shove it in their face you
have YouTube channel no no that people
people can choose to watch it or they
don't choose to watch it kiss if what if
I think in general if I'm in public
public of affection are gross I I'm not
really into I've never really been into
the public displays of affection in
general but gay people throw it in your
face they have they have Flags dedicated
to but if there's two men walking down
the street holding hands like let them
hold their here's the why does it bother
you so much that you have to make one
day one day you're going to have
children and it when you make it normal
then it confuses the
kids when he get when it gets that that
that it's the in the schools then it's
like all right that's
used accept
that but the thing is it used to it used
to be like what you did in the bedroom
was your business and nobody asked
questions and that's my problem with it
today is now they're making it super
public when it's supposed to be just
like whatever you I'm not going to go
look in your bedroom I don't care okay
but I just don't like when they throw it
in our
face so and I agree
but I age that like all across the board
it's not just with like gay people I I
don't care who you are like public
displays of affection are just do you
have kids of course I have kids okay so
that's what I'm saying is that it
affects the kids you're saying well why
why does it matter why does it bother
you Pearl why does it bother you because
of the kids I'm saying as two adults a
male and a female walking down the
street and two males walking down the
street that it does not affect you there
are no kids around there is no reason
for you to be be casting out a gay slur
because
have puppies tell you you you have no
kids in that sitation I have kids public
show if public show of affection between
heterosexual couples which is
biologically the way that we reproduce
is looked down upon what makes you think
that public show of dep of affection
between two a man and a man or a woman
and a woman should be accepted like she
just said she just said and and which I
agree with you I don't even think a man
and a woman should be showing each other
too much affection in public out out in
public or being too I'm not I'm not
making an argument for I'm not making an
argument for them to be doing public
display or affection what they do
though they have whole parades on
streets they have whole restaurants
dedicated to them so much so that
they're even putting it in the school so
much so that I think it's in California
that if if your child goes to you and
says I want to be a boy and he's a and
she's a girl and you say no you're a
girl and she goes and tells her teacher
my father doesn't uh doesn't uh assign
what what do they call it a affirm my
gender they can come and take my
children from me you're tell we're
having two different arguments no no no
I'm saying that it all applies into the
same argument because they're doing that
right now the new Lightyear movie they
had two women kissing I did not allow my
son to watch that movie as much as I
love Toy Story they're putting it
everywhere Arthur uh M what's his name
Mr Ratburn is a homosexual you're
telling me that they're not attacking
our children yeah no they are I'm not
they have a song that we're not I'm say
yeah you're saying that we shouldn't
judge them we openly judge each other on
a daily basis on everything the moment
you see me or I see you I'm already
making a judgment on who I think you are
and what I think you do and you're doing
it the same thing even then you are
subconsciously no she's oh my goodness I
know I don't I don't you do to this
biological I grew up in a gay household
my mom was a lesbian and I thought
growing up that was my mom's roommate I
never found out my mom was a lesbian
till I turned 15 years old that my I
accidentally saw my mom kissing her
partner and that's when my mom had to
come out and tell me but they were
already living for seven years mind you
they would do everything together to me
that was my mom's best friend I never
saw no kissing I never saw no affection
no nothing my mom was so embarrassed
that she locked me in the room with her
and she asked me how I felt about it
obviously I told her how I felt about it
that I wasn't okay with it that I felt
disrespected that I felt betrayed
because she didn't let me know and what
did my mom say it is not your right to
know so can I ask you a question real
quick has she been honest with you from
the beginning how do you feel about gay
people in general before they suck just
I wouldn't say they suck they lit but
they do because so but but do you feel
like maybe the the you have this you
have this the reason you have this this
outlook on on on gay people is because
you have maybe that that distrust with
your mom that she absolutely not because
I can go up to my mom and talk to her
about everything my mom no you can't do
you do you a
question my entire life my entire life
you like your mom I love my mom okay so
so no trauma no there is absolutely no
trauma traumatize family MERS
no why don't why don't you guys believe
her what is it are you traumatized no I
am not no I'm not
saying I actually appreciate never
show with another woman how would I
would have felt when my friends would
have came over seeing my mom and her
partner kissing that's embarrassing yeah
and you are het you're heterosexual now
I'm sorry you're heterosexual yes you
don't like okay but isn't the isn't the
whole argument here this could D you
know the children and she was 50 I mean
I suppose
I guess you could arue they started
living together when I was around cuz I
came back from Columbia around 78 so
they started living together around that
age when I came back they were already
living together so they were in a very
long-term relationship bought a house
and everything we moved to Texas and I
promise you I never saw them in no type
of kissing or nothing because my mom
knew that I was she kep she kept we
would go out out all of us together and
there was no holding hands we would be
in the car and there was no holding hand
I never saw no argument I never saw
guess you could argue they did the right
thing then so they were you know they
were they conducted it in a way that it
didn't affect have you got brothers and
sisters no I'm an only child okay so but
they did it in a way they conducted it
in a way that you know kept it like what
you're saying they kept it private they
kept it in the bedroom which is which is
right I guess not right well I mean that
you know in the context of having
relationship she was trying to avoid me
from having traumas and becoming a
lesbian we respect it a little more
confusion they didn't allow her to be
confused so I have um I have a question
so I actually I want to bring it back to
Miami dating a little bit um so why is
it why is the culture so [__] in Miami
what's going on here I'm from Charlotte
I don't know what yeah it's based off
that fact that um social media and um
everyone has so many options and no one
really has that um what they had back in
the day everyone wanting to work it out
and fig and make get it get it done
everyone's so quick to leave because
there are so many options it's like you
don't have to stick around for something
that isn't completely fulfilling you and
because it's easy to leave people do
okay can I can I ask you guys a quick
question you cut her off at any time can
can I ask you you you girls a quick
question because I'm obviously from
London I've come here quite a lot so I
kind of know it a bit I've got I've got
I got
friends I got I got friends here and Stu
like that but is it would you say is it
easier for guys to date here or for
women to date here for guys or for girls
to dat is it easier for for GU for girls
to to find you know guys here or is it
easier for guys to find girls here it's
easier for guys to finds from from the
guys perspective we would say so I've
coached guys out here right I've got
I've got clients who live here and stuff
like that and and we would say the
problem with Miami for for dating
there's obviously there's a lot of hot
women here 100% a lot of hot Latinos and
you know everybody else wandering around
however Latinas exactly however lots of
Puerto Ricans lots of Colombians however
um there's also a lot of very high value
men there's a lot of guys with a lot of
money with a lot of Clouts with a lot of
Fame with a lot of celebrity so that
means for the average dude it's probably
going to be harder because these women
have got all of these options would you
agree with that you think that's fair I
would say there's um a decent amount of
high value guys but the high value guys
want multiple women they don't want just
one rightly
so and you guys are all [__] the same
ones all 10 all I would argue I would
argue that a lot of high value men uh
exercise sexual discipline yeah real
real high a real high value I would just
say that the women in Miami don't have
the anybody don't have the standards so
everybody's sleeping with everybody
because it's so nasty in Miami because
women are just they can do whatever they
want I can do whatever I want body
autonomy whatever whatever but nobody
takes the time to respect their own body
they would rather have the [__] the
high value man instead of just I have a
I have a question for the ladies here
raise your hand if you've ever had a
celebrity slide in your
DMs right what did you so one two three
four wow so that's
okay okay yeah so did raise your hand
any of you meet
him no okay I was actually on a podcast
with him just the other day who who was
it I don't well I he has a girl right
now so I don't want to say anything okay
it's fine it's you have to
say know wow
sorry that's just celebrities
even that that underlines my point
because we've got a major clear majority
of the women here have had at least one
celebrity slide into their DMS in Miami
right so what does that say for the
average dude in the street who's working
you know who's who's working in public
chance exactly so you know it
seems I I think especially in Miami I
think that there's this thing that
everybody thinks they're the main
character and and so it's like everyone
is too good for everyone and so instead
of getting to know somebody and being
like oh this is another human being and
let me find out about this person and
maybe we have something to connect on
everybody wants to be like you know what
I mean oh you don't have enough money
you know what I mean like toas
see I mean that's a quality car I love
Toyotas I love Toyota and girls will go
on our podcast and say they will never
sit in a Toyota no do you know what I
really I like Honda sit then I [__]
mile
really I love I love Lexis because Lex
is very reliable as long as you like
change the oil Lex is a
Toyota go like what cars I'm curious
okay so what industries do women
typically date here like if you guys had
to pick an industry like
Bankers I would say the hospitality like
industry Hospitality what about you oh
me yeah I I like businessmen businessman
businessman I'm still trying to figure
that out cuz I just came out of a
seven-year relationship so it's not like
I'm out there looking for someone so I'm
still trying to figure that out you're
so
cute she's innocent you guys stay away
she's
innocent yeah uh I see that a lot of
girls here in Miami are dating YouTubers
podcasters guys that own luxury
companies uh cars cars private jets yeah
is that a bad you know the Beautiful You
know the beautiful thing about Miami all
these guys [__] you and then let you go
back into the wild easy it's like
Pokemon trainers they [__] you and then
let you go right back out that's why I
say a woman should figure
out that's why I said a woman should
figure out what she wants in life and
get her own money because when you have
your own money you don't pick a Man
based off what he provides for you you
pick a Man based off how he treats you
that's just what they do wom wom don't
pick men women don't women don't pick
men the man PI what's the what's the
point of relationships love love okay
what is love for me it's someone that um
mutual respect open communication
loyalty honesty it's just like having
each other's back knowing that hey this
is your journey in life this is your
journey in life let's do it together
okay do you think love is a
choice yeah okay so I I think
relationships are about family and Duty
that that's what I think the goal of
that's what I think the goal of
relationships are so I I think the
question when you say a backup plan you
know I think like what is your goal my
goal yeah um right now I would be def
find a partner that I feel is like the
other half of me someone that because my
last partner he um he hindered me a lot
in life I would be a lot F even though
I'm really good for
29 for 20 years what is what has
hindered like he he like held me back
like I'd be at the office and he'd pop
up to the office and start drama at the
office and try and get like and you were
just a perfect angel you never had any I
I came from a very small town I came
from a does it doesn't it doesn't matter
very strong no no it does if you let me
listen let me finish very strong family
values I when I first came to Miami I
didn't know what dating was I thought
that when you asked a girl to be on a
relationship you guys were together it
was just you I didn't realize dating is
dating multiple people I've only been
with one person I'm a very loyal person
right and that made you perfect no I'm
the what makes me perfect is that I
never did anything to upset him I never
stepped out on him I never disrespected
him I've never heard somebody just claim
to be
perfect you just said it you said I'm
perfect because what what I done what
did I do to make what's not what's not
don't know your relationship but tell me
things that I can do that would make me
not I what she's trying to say is that
she didn't do anything outwardly but
that be you can be oblivious to your own
faults okay if he if I was such a bad
partner why am you're a bad
partner clim to be perfect you can't
nobody saying nobody's saying you were a
bad partner we're saying that everybody
has flaws everyone has flaw so you're
not perfect and you'll never be a
perfect partner say I was in in in my
relationship my partner boasted about me
to people he showed me off I mean
Kardashian got showed off three
times it wasn't it
wasn't yeah it was yeah it was more
about my looks he always boasted about
how smart I was the fact that we were
business partners we were 50/50 business
partners we literally built and
destroyed and rebuilt houses together
like we were a perfect team if he did
not like men we would still be together
today but then if y'all was so perfect
why couldn't you look past the fact that
he was by because I don't want to be
with a man that's with other men but
then that means as perfect as you may
claim to be what what then you're not
you're saying we're perfect we were
business we were this we were this we
that so if you are in a loving
relationship and I correct me I could be
wrong I don't know but if you're in a
loving relationship you and you love
this man you guys are perfect you
business this that sex whatever then you
will stay with them with their faults
you will work through sexual orientation
no that that is a hard no could I just
ask a quick question though did he did
he was it the point that he would have
said okay listen I I maybe I am bisexual
but I'm with you babe so this is going
to be it it's just going to be us did he
sort of say that kind of thing no no no
he so was it he want he would want to
carried on seeing yeah he would do it
behind my back sh okay but let's leave
him out of the picture you you just said
that you've been with how many men 18
eight so let's leave him out of the
picture why didn't the other men work
out my first one um my first first one
was a high school relationship my mom
took me from my high school um when I
was 17 just why why the relationships
out if you're so perfect oh oh cuz I
wasn't trying to be in um like a
long-term relationship so you're telling
me you were out here [__] seven other
guys or six other guys um and you're
Miss and none of them wanted five other
guys you also said that you you said
that you were just you didn't know what
dating and being together was you were
dating them and they don't was it
exclusive um I was only exclusive with
the very first the first three I was
exclusive with yeah and then the one the
ones after I'm confused no she got Ted
by Miami that's what happened no no in
the last year I've been dating but I
haven't been dating for a relationship I
don't want to I haven't been wanting a
relation I've been wanting my own space
so when I was dating it was just for me
needing the physical attention like the
physical touch you know the penetra dick
yes
basically believe it or
not even even when women are independent
they still need men that [__] crazy sex
yeah for sure do you say anything else
like is there anything else that I say a
lot I say a lot I I no I just I say but
I say I say the truth I just think no
it's people are look I mean people I
think people are right to sort of it is
a bit capto set to sort of imply that
you're perfect in a relationship because
nobody's perfect you you probably didn't
step out not not one of them was your
fault like not
one listen um
nothing the last five I have not tried
to um I have not tried to have a
relationship with him it was purely like
I enjoy having time with you I want to
spend time with you time yeah I do I
have my entire life yes I do so
you're 60 year olds are not if you hit
30 and you're still single you're more
likely to not reproduce than reproduce I
don't want to reproduce it's not okay
well if you don't if you don't want to
have kids that's fine but I'm saying
it's more likely that you will if you
hit 35 and you're not married it's like
a 15% chance you'll ever marry so like
statistically complete you um it does no
it doesn't it does you know I would
argue there are some women that are too
damaged to be completed by marriage not
saying that's
you but I don't but you know I I do
think for most women I mean if you look
at antidepressant usage for women over
the age of 45 when they're single and
unmarried it's typically pretty bad mhm
oh yeah so yeah I would say for most
women they do feel incomplete without a
man oh well I'm not most women um I feel
very complete on my own and I will are
we are we can I ask a question so for
the rest of this are we going to always
argue that the exception or we're going
to talk General I like
her talk about me specifically that's
why we're talking about me just cuz it
gets really confusing because when we
sit here and we say I I I I I I I well
they were asking me direct questions
General General
statement I feel bad for the animals
that can't leave think about the puppies
they want to leave think about the dogs
the cats man like have a real
conversation I'm being I'm being honest
though they did they did a study and
they said that by 2030 most women are
going to have animals they're not even
going to want kids anymore like I'm to
leave an animal sanctuary behind so it's
literally part my all your animals even
the rate of depression is higher than
it's ever been the rate I was thinking
about sing mothers I think women should
be banned from owning pets thank you
yeah yeah and I have a dog I get to keep
I get except for me I get to keep
mine okay but why do you say that though
oh because there's a couple trends that
I see that are quite weird are these
these women doing [__] with their dogs
I've I've heard I said that I've heard
of this this is weird that's some weird
[__] we got to stop
oh there's some Insel accounts on
there's some Insel accounts on Twitter
who are going about that like you see
then despised by women they'd rather
[__] their dogs whether it's true or not
I don't know no no no there's some
there's some girls that have gone to
like gotten in trouble for it it's like
a thing there's there's girls that put
like peanut butter in their [__] yeah
yeah that's that's just what and these
dogs do can't do anything but do it cuz
you know well and I see how women well
and I see how women take care I see how
women take care of their kids so I'm
like they obviously can't take care of
the dogs any better you know I mean like
I mean we look at the outcomes of single
mother homes are terrible but these dogs
are going to be better it's going to
have a lot of stre single okay question
about plastic surgery in Miami okay all
right raise your hand men and women
who's had plastic surgery here raise
your
hand yeah obviously you do have that
obviously I got I got a B can you just
hang
out he's a girl he came out right now I
got a BBL from her company really no
plastic surgery none none okay I'm
surprised I thought it would be the
majority based I mean if you go to the
beach there's plenty of plastic surgery
out there I didn't realize men got
plastic surgery till I came
here I saw did you get done I saw the
first time the ab uh what's it called
the ab thing what is it called I got AB
edging yeah I heard I heard that I saw
that today for the first time just got a
BBL I just got one and he didn't get
bodged
soer I don't understand
I don't understand how he doesn't have
his BBL pillow going on right now you
cannot be doing that but you you sell
plastic you sell cosmetic surgery yes so
what what's the CLE onel like that that
comes to you um it's really good because
in my clinic I cannot dispose who I work
with but in my clinic it's not like I'm
like out here calling people it's just
people that are inquiring because it's
already um a known surgeon okay it's
interesting actually because a lot of
people will go to Columbia won't they or
we recommend not to do that because in
Colombia they will take and Dominican
Republic and all these um places will
take more fat than were they're supposed
to and they will even end up selling
your organs without you knowing so you
come back to the US without a lung or
something and correct me if I'm wrong
but a lot of Surgeons if you get your
surgery done in another country some
surgeons here see for example so
something happens exactly so we we we
ask personal questions like if you ever
had a miscarriage or if if you've ever
like G gone through any other surgeries
and stuff like that and if you've gone
to another country out of the US to get
surgery you cannot get surgery with her
surgeon what are the most popular
treatments for women and for men here
then I would say I would say BBL BPL and
I would say lipo 360 are the most
BBL yes but it's not as common as BBL
because in Miami remember everybody runs
through that and most of the women that
are getting surgery are honestly black
women and they're getting B so what did
you get uh BBL 360 anything else or just
BBL no no Botox filler oh yeah oh yeah I
do go I do do Botox okay shout out to
party she sees all that [__] not
regularly but I do do it um and filler I
just started doing that no one else no
Botox Botox I thought we weren't
counting that that counts what the
that's not plastic surgery that's just
something I mean I is it that's not it's
it's no it's a COS it's a cosmetic
procedure I agree with no I when you say
plas I was being like a little bit when
you said plastic yeah like plastic
surgery like yeah what if what if a
woman's attitude was a cosmetic
procedure they won I think that I think
that unfortunately my bad man
unfortunately women are quicker to fix
their body than to fix their attitude
Yes actually I'd like to go around fun
fun thing what's one thing you could
improve about yourself myself yeah
everyone go around uh one thing I could
improve about myself in regards to just
me as a person MH I think I could be
more disciplined more disciplined Troy
what do you think oh Jesus Christ
nothing absolutely nothing no I I think
I think
well I kind of want to copy him I think
discipline is very important I mean I
strive to be as disciplined as I can and
I go through periods when I am very
disciplined other times it can go a
little bit Haywire particularly with
traveling so I would probably cosign
that I
think I would say
procrastination I'm probably I'm an time
person but I if you tell me to do
something I will wait till the last
minute to do it I will wait what about
you oh my God the list is long there's
so many things I would deter or not
determination uh
discipline discipline 1,00% I'm very
very gentle with myself when I'm like
when I want to give up I give up I've
gotten better though I've gotten a lot
better with myself um and yeah
procrastination
um and I think think I would be more
aware of my
temper what do you do you Yeller she
almost punch me in her face you almost
you stood up first she almost he stood
up first listen you stood up to me so
but you didn't stand up to the other guy
which
why huh you throw hands yeah no what
I've gotten better obviously I'm I'm
older now
but I listen as far as I would never
ever put my hands on anybody ever unless
I unless I felt like I had to I'm
Colombian I would never ever ever I
would never no no no no no no when I was
younger listen when I was younger when I
was younger definitely like probably I
would be like yeah step step not even
cuz I like you honest I wouldn't but I
really like you Pearl what a day what a
day I've made my new best
friend I already have two friends when I
move here yeah know and you know what I
think I honestly I like the fact that we
have different personalities cuz I think
we could really learn from each other
you know like I no I think you guys
could learn from
me okay bro all right BR I haven't
learned one
thing okay except maybe hitting I think
that's
new but um but yeah that would be it
that that's it okay what about you my
hyper Independence hyper in okay so how
would you improve that um I guess all
the things you've said have indicated
you do not want to improve that yeah
yeah no no well no I just don't want to
limit myself because I've been limited
before and I just don't want to do that
ever again what does limit yourself my
partner like I couldn't like me choosing
what job to do and when to do them and
like just like he literally alienated me
from my all my friends and he attempted
to do it with my family so it was just
like it's like a really big so
so why all right how did he do that um
okay he didn't like you a quick version
so did he didn't want you to hang out
with certain friends oh any no friends
he had to be there every time okay so
why were you with him for eight years
though we were great friends okay so
when I first moved here I I wasn't from
here so he became one of my he was my
best friend you know and I didn't know
many people except for the people that I
worked with and then every time I would
create a bond with someone that I work
with he would find ways were they guys
or girls girls okay but guys are like
too he didn't like it either but um
girls it was just like he alen it and
then my family
um he bought me this um magnet for the
fridge and um when my parents were my
parent my mom and my sister were staying
with me and because we always kept
multiple households and cuz I always
have a house for my animals so that my
animals can have their own house and
then we had our house where we live and
our families were
together at me like that yeah they get
their on the house that's why he left he
he left he did not leave Eric he left
because you liked your animals more than
you did him he was jealous of my animals
though he even threatened to kill one
and every time he got upset with me he
okay why are you dating crazy men this
man sounds crazy it's only men it's only
one or she's crazy no I'm not well we
know
but but like um I think it was um the
fact that we created such a strong bond
and we were like and I told you like I
like when I'm in a relationship with
someone I don't give up like I'm a very
persistent person that's the that's the
thing about me and I didn't want to give
up the only reason why I gave up is
because the sexual orientation that was
something that I couldn't get past yeah
do you know what's funny you're like I'm
not the person to give up and then you
said but I gave up I had to I had to
because I get it I get it I get it you
know I get well yeah did he not say
because were you in a monogamous
relationship though so didn't he say so
when you confronted him about this
didn't he say well yeah but that's
that's deny deny deny he just denied
kept denying even though I had literally
physical proof of him in videos and
stuff he would just deny it and and to
this day I can literally take list I
have he he sounds a bit crazy he's a
narcissist do you do you believe you
attract what every every man is a
narcissist I mean in a way yeah there's
certain definitely for sure but for
me I was young and naive and fell in
love and F and fell in love with someone
and I just did not want to give up with
them because I've always come from very
like my parents they're they've been
together my whole life they're still
together like family's always been
strong with me so I figured oh this is
my partner there's ups and downs in a
relationship let's work it out and so
that's what we did we literally every
time we had ups and and downs we figured
it out but I I personally just could not
get over the the man no I I get that but
you realize like you're basically going
to make men of the future pay for the
mistakes of your past because if you're
you you you mention that you were afraid
to be in that situation again and
therefore you always need a backup plan
and you always it's not really a backup
plan it's my path in life it's not a
backup plan okay okay you you mentioned
something about being I can't remember
the exact wording you said but something
about being very scared to be in that
situation again and and my point was
just it's just making the men of the
future pay for the mistakes of your past
when you're more guarded with men of the
future I'm not really I I wouldn't say
I'm really guarded it's just that now
that I have my own life and I'm very
secure in myself I get to choose and
pick the partner that's right for me
based off love I don't need a man I want
a man and that for me is two very big
how does how do women pick men usually
well when they they for for what for in
normal women pick based off what they
can provide for them the way no no I
mean like when women pick for love do
women typically pick well oh I would say
so yeah if it's for love if it's for
genuine love and caring no if it's for
if it's for love I would say in the last
hundred years women have had more Choice
than ever so in the 1920s that was
actually the first sexual Revolution and
that was when women basically got more
Choice than ever before in picking a
partner would you say women pick better
now or they picked better before the 20s
I think think before the 2080 they had
better options to pick from we do not
have that many good options at this
point you're picking the top 10% we
already T about the no I'm not ping the
man doesn't have to have money you went
on my podcast and said your guy has to
make over 100k I said no you said you're
perfect build your perfect guy I told
you my perfect guy but I'm realistic the
guys that I've datting in the past few
years they don't make as much money as
me except for like you make more than
them so what do you think your perfect
guy wants from you um probably what you
guys say respect you don't have that
respect first yes I do I respect I'm
very respect respectful um respect first
and say again com well I have an opinion
I'm have an opinion no you could you can
have an opinion you can have an opinion
and not be combative when a man when a
man when a woman is submissive to her
husband because you guys like to say
partner you're not saying husband you
want a partner right when a when a woman
is submissive to her husband that means
she selected him because of his
leadership characteristics right she's
willing to yield to his authority
because she trusts him and leading them
through life just because he's leading
her doesn't mean that he's not going to
consider her opinion why women have an
intuition that men don't have right but
you guys have a role just because you're
you have an opinion doesn't make you
combative and just because you're
combative doesn't mean that a man is
going to be willing to listen to your
opinion because at that point you're
just arguing to argue you're not willing
to listen to anything that anybody's
saying I listen to everyone I speak no
you're hearing us you hear me but I'm I
hear you and I listen in our respon so
what are what are three things what are
three things that you think the man that
you want wants from you respect
submissiveness and femininity okay what
does submissiveness look like to you I
not being combative okay but now you're
just repeating what I'm saying to you
that's what you want I don't want
anything from you that's what men want
not particular no I don't want anything
I want you to be honest that's what I'm
being what do you think okay what do you
think submissiveness looks like um like
describe describe a woman's sub
submissiveness
uh whatever I don't know like basically
submitting to what it depends on what
the man wanton do you want me to tell
you what submissiveness is from a woman
power a woman's willingness to submit to
a man that's where her power comes from
women can stop Wars women can start wars
from being submissive to the right man
right but you guys disassociated that
with power you guys think that being
like men is your power when in reality
being a feminine woman is your power the
ability to submit to a a strong leader
is your power
Men When a Man Loves a Woman right he's
willing to listen to her for example we
spoke about this the other day if I'm
going if if if if if I'm married right
and I'm going to go do business with
another married man somewhere somewhere
along the dinner I'm going to ask my
wife or even prior to the dinner I'm
going to tell my wife hey 5 minutes
after we're done
eating say hey let's go to the bathroom
ladies because I know how I know how
much of uh his wife's opinion he's going
to take it's strategic
right it's strategic a man's going to
say yo he listens to his wife too much I
don't need her around I don't need her
hearing what I'm saying or listening to
what I'm being told so let me go ahead
and talk to him directly because a woman
is very well uh capable of influencing
her man we do consider our women's
opinion but we don't consider combative
women we don't consider disagreeable
women he always asked when like I said
we work together we were sitting at the
same table he always asked me in my
opinion and actually he let me lead most
times and see and probably because he
probably because he was
bisexual men men could no it's more than
likely that's what it is because a woman
a feminine woman doesn't want to lead in
a relationship I don't want to I wasn't
leading in the relationship but in
business I have my own mind he respected
my mind so he did allow me to take lead
because women are terrible in business
thank you no you you're running a
business you think you're terrible at it
um I'm terrible at a lot of things thank
God I have men to help me did you
I think did you see me set up any of
this equipment no no what's your name is
Christin Christy I think that you've
just had very bad experiences with men
and Miss pear it no no no no you've been
in one relationship with a man but
you've been with several men right and I
think it's a valid point I think it's a
valid exactly I think it's a very valid
point what she asked you she asked you
if it was such a bad relationship with
the one that you were with a years what
was it about you a bad one but you said
he was a homosexual and he had that's
the only thing that's not big that's a
big thing yeah only deal okay okay and
her question was what about the other
five the other guy the I I've been on my
own Journey since I told you how he
hindered me Journey no no cuz he
hindered me he hindered me a lot in like
cuz like he financially took over like
even though we were making all the money
he financially took over I put myself in
a bad positioning allowing him to take
care of the finances I left him with
$400 in my bank account and had six or
seven Grand of bills each month I had to
grind and when I was do that I was to I
don't even spend that much you
know M cars multiple houses and you know
what's crazy what's ironic that if you
would have prioritized femininity if you
would have started operating in Your
Divine femininity a man would have came
and took care of all of that I don't
want a man to take care of it that's
what I'm saying I don't want I don't
want to have to provide I don't want to
have to bend mold or morph myself into
being something want to submit you don't
want to sub I will submit to the right
you don't want I will submit to the
right man you don't want to submit you
don't want to be led and you don't want
to respect I do but which is why what
Pearl is saying is that you're going to
make every guy pay for your ex's mistake
no they're not you don't you're already
doing it you're already understand it I
know I'm listening very carefully to
what you're saying sexual guy two years
two years ago you left him so you're
telling me it's taking you two years to
find
yourself you are you trying to put a
time stamp on my healing
Journey yeah I think we should start
yeah actually no I want to answer this
question no I I want to answer this
question yes yes because I've done I've
done 150 shows uh plus I've interviewed
probably roughly a thousand people and I
am so [__] sick of hearing about
healing but you need to heal everyone
need relationship Rel I need you to
finish I need you to let me finish so
I'm I'm tired of hearing about two
things healing and Trauma ladies it's
time to take the L and get over it it's
time to yes yes yes yes I'm tired of
hearing about the abuse of EX I'm tired
of hearing about the toxic ex you know
what our grandmothers our great grandm
grandmothers took and moved on they
didn't cry for years but that's what I
did I moved on I've you had sex christe
christe yo but you I'm going to give you
six months six months there's your
healing jumping from relationship
relationship within 6 months you're not
really healing and you're the one that's
actually taking I'll give you
eight but after but after that
relationship in two years you've had six
bodies five five bodies that's a lot of
healing right there that's that's a lot
of healing right there I would argue
that I would argue that that's a lot of
Destruction how are you healing by
allowing a man five different men to
enter your body in two years if you're
supposed to be healing that doesn't make
sense I'm heal like when I said healing
journ is is time for myself for time for
me to figure out what I wanted in life
you're not understanding what he's
saying no I understand what he's saying
100% I'm you understand English but
you're not understanding what I'm saying
what I'm saying if you were truly
healing yourself and it truly took you 2
years you wouldn't even allow another
man to enter your body you're not
understanding how powerful that is how
much of I understand it but what I'm
saying is that I have needs just like
you have needs you have needs which is
why you have a girlfriend but you [__]
other girls together I have physical
needs that need to be care and I chose
my partners what has more value in your
opinion a physical need or the need to
heal yourself
both I've been in Miami for s days you
guys not everyone thinks like that do
not think that women all women in Miami
thinks like that no no no no that that's
crazy long
years okay I want to go back to the
self-improvement what do you think you
could do to improve yourself because
she's perfect she's perfect uh yeah I
would just say patience for me patience
that's what I was going to say too I can
be pretty impatient
patience um I would say I would stop
procrastinating and by being more
disciplined
she just said everything they said no
yeah but when she came up to it I was
like oh that was I was just okay so you
said not all Miami girls are like that
so I want to actually go to the next
question you know what is the average
body count for a woman that lives in
Miami you guys think now I'm gonna I'm
going to let you I'm goingon to start
here and then go around I just the
average body count yeah the average
let's let's say a 25y old woman let's
say 25 I would say five probably five in
Miami like in Miami oh no I would say
like you and me girls are 25 with 35
body counts so the
average 1520 1520 okay that's like being
nice okay so not being nice but being
honest a good 30 30 okay uh Miami women
are born with 10
bodies and um a 25-year old probably has
around 30 to 40 bodies yeah
Jesus um that's on a that's on a on the
nice side by the way I've had girls come
on a podcast say they [__] 200 guys in
one year so that's
crazy right I'd imagine that but it is
more common it is becoming more common
so I'm I'm thinking like you meet a
normal 25-year-old chick in Miami it's
safe to assume she's [__] yeah 30 40
bodies 30 40 okay I would say 20 to 30
20 to 30
same yeah I'm 26 but I don't have that
many well I'm just going to go
going be 50 but I mean maybe you guys
probably know better than me so they're
starting young that's the problem to be
fair I just got here so I and how many
bodies do you have I have eight okay and
how old are you 26 so I have the same
amount of bodies as someone who's
younger than me wow well I would say
that my particular situation very open
wow my particular situation I only the
people I had sex with I was in heading
towards relationships with heading
towards carrying a lot of white because
AKA healing stage no no I'm not not
saying anything about healing St believe
in
that you had this is what I mean heading
towards because when I talk to a guy
like he say when you what's your body
count what's your body count well like
he said when when you talk to somebody
when you date somebody you date with the
intentions to marry to do that so I
would say I did that when I dated a guy
and if I took some L's I took some L's
you took a lot of L L's how many how
many were you in a relationship with
well I was act I was actually in four
relationships um my longest relationship
was 2 years okay oh well no I'm in my
longest relationship this one's three a
[__] was getting a little warm I almost
forgot about this oh sorry babe I almost
forgot about this relationship three
okay so yeah and this is why the father
is important in the house I'm just
curious the the whole you guys are
saying your body counts and stuff you
realize you're going to have like kids
someday they could watch
this like I'm just very like very
forthcoming all right well I mean like
you guys said the average 25y old yes
probably does have they're starting
young these kids are I'm a high school
cheerleading coach kids are 16 year olds
I understand 12 [__] so yeah so the
average 25y old now does have 25 but I I
didn't start having sex until I was 18
same same so it's like different and I
and I will say I did have a like a stage
where I broke up with a boyfriend got
too crazy but then I ended up back into
a relationship and then that's when I
started so um back to all right
situationships wait so okay actually
we're gonna that's G to be my next
question everyone's at like
25ish 30 they're saying you said 50
what' you say the average I've just been
in Miami for like seven days so I
wouldn't know but I mean if I were to
guess probably around 15 20 25 maybe 25
so let's talk about
situationships all right um is a
situationship at a talking stage the
same thing no no I think a situationship
is when you're actually physically doing
stuff isn't it where the talking phase
is probably with no strings attached is
that a
situationship so from from my
understanding cuz I have a friend who
says she's in a situationship it's they
don't know if they want to be together
so they're together but they're not
together yeah and then but but they
don't want to know if each other is
sleeping with something somebody else
yeah it's like an oblivious kind break
down cuz I just hear all these terms so
we're going to go situation she's going
to make another pyramid no this is this
is
entangle Pear's losing brain cells right
now bro right I believe I've never been
in a situationship married well well I
we know what guys I'm actually gonna I'm
dating I apprciate appreciate you yeah
I'm actually going to head out we got
some B okay very nice to meet you guys
I I want everyone to be involved in this
because I hear all these I always ask
women and this is more very nice to meet
you very nice to meet you Catholics
right
yeah damn ladies where' you find this I
just so okay so we have so I always when
I start shows oftentimes I get very
vague answers I say are you guys in a
relationship or you seeing someone and
so we get situationship entanglement
complicated dating seeing someone let's
define these like seeing someone is
dating yeah right isn't that the same
well or no seeing someone is just
[__] let's be honest but a
situationship is as well no
situationship is like me and you are
dating and then you can control me but I
can control you but we're only
[__] isn't that what it is just came
out of the I that's like a situationship
it's a whole mess some [__] no
situationship is what she Bush when you
say no when you say I'm seeing someone
it's just like you're just meeting up
with a
guy you guys can't get your own issues
together to say you're together feel the
need to control the woman and the woman
feels the need to control without being
anything way if I said I'm in a
situationship what would you guys assume
i' assume you were saying some dude
dudes but it wasn't confirmed yet what
the you know we're not together we're
not boyfriend and girlfriend you're
probably you're having sex but it's
not so situationship is so you're kind
of seeing each other but it's not
defined as anything you give each other
as a situation because like she said
there's some strings attached but it's
like a situationship [__] but not
defined no no say a situationship is
where you give each other the boyfriend
and girlfriend experience but there's no
title okay so are they sleeping with
other people both of them usually they
might they might be okay so okay so I
have a question in a in a typical
situationship in a typical situationship
is the girl sleeping with someone else
they might they might be they
might raise your hand if you think the
girl is sleeping with someone else in
Miami yes this we're in Miami okay raise
your hand if the boy is sleeping with
someone else but they're like each
other's favorites yeah okay so don't
they're each other's mean and they don't
communicate they don't they're not going
to talk about the others that's can I
explain entanglement cuz this one's a
good one okay so yeah you wanted to
bring up so if I said I'm in an
entanglement an entanglement does that
mean I'm screwing a 19-year-old like
Jada an entanglement means when you are
in a kind of like a
relationship and then there's somebody
else that you're also interested in and
you guys kind of play flirt and maybe
you do something but it's like it's an
entanglement the feelings are here and
over there and then here so it's like
we're friend okay are we are we having
are we it's when multiple people kind of
have like okay I need to all right let's
let's break this down so so if it's me
am if I'm in an entanglement am I
sleeping with somebody you could be am I
or not I'm trying to Define yes you
could be yes okay so I'm sleeping with
one person but then I have feelings for
another right okay that's an
entanglement yeah like say you're you're
in a relationship with this guy Troy Mr
Troy here and then you meet him and you
kind of like him too and you guys flirt
and maybe have
sex okay so two guys two guys at once or
vice versa or vice versa yeah but
feelings but feelings for both but
wouldn't you say that he she could be
she could also be sort of in the in the
talking phase with him though couldn't
because she might be if I was the mate
she might be like say you're dating
multiple people yeah but you're not
being very forward cominging with is it
more like so is it more like in a
situation sh is it more like in a
situationship where it's like okay we're
these two are the mains but maybe we're
sleeping around but it it doesn't mean
anything whereas this one it's a bit
more like okay she's the main but maybe
I'm seeing her over here a bit and
there's something a bit more serious
here as well go of your options
basically okay these sound really
similar no to be honest this sounds this
situationship and entanglement kind of
sounds the same to me no but
situationship you're not doing that with
a bunch of people we just said we just
said they were we just raised our hands
and they said what do you mean it's
possible yeah yeah yeah okay usually
situationships are two uh someone two
people who don't want to commit to each
other for whatever reason but they're
still getting together like a boyfriend
and girlfriend right entanglement
they're dating someone and cheating
basically and they're just not being
honest with each other so it's
complicated complicated means
they're it's complicated it's
complicated if it was easy we would be
to Define it right I would say
complicated would be like you guys are
both like you and him are just like
having sex but you guys don't want to be
together okay what it's weird like you
make everybody all all all right but
these but these all sound exactly the
same they're not because it's a bunch of
[__] yeah yeah she's got a point but
isn't isn't it's complicated the kind of
thing you say when you don't really know
what the deal is so you know you'll be
seeing somebody but you don't really
know what their deal is you don't know
if they really like you so when some
your friend asks you okay so what's are
you seeing somebody you go well it's
complicated because you don't really
know what she thinks you think it's an
excuse for you to be able to do whatever
you want all these are an excuse okay
okay it's fine we're going to we're
going to go through I just want to get
these okay dating if I say I'm dating
someone is that my boyfriend yeah I
think that's you're exclusive dating is
like we're we're kind really cuz when
someone says they're dating I don't
assume they have a boyfriend or a
girlfriend I would think they're like
going on this is what I would think I
would think they're like going on
maybe like maybe maybe yeah yeah yeah
that's what I would think would you
disagree yes before tonight did you know
any of this [__] uh not really no I'm
making it up I don't think men really
know this yeah but you some people some
people you find out some people will say
dating around though they'll say yeah
I'm dating around and that will indicate
you know they're seeing different dating
around is different than dating oh [__]
I think I think for men is different
like I think for men it's either we're
taking her seriously or we're not yeah I
would agree yeah that's really all it
comes down to okay seeing someone that's
like dating that's dating that's
basically all all right I'm going to put
entanglement complicated and
situationship is the same thing and
dating and seeing someone is the same
thing you can put dating as um you're
dating multiple people and you're going
around you're looking for a partner and
then seeing some all these no I think
dating is just like relationship okay so
let's let's talk about in Miami all
right in Miami in Miami if you want to
get into a real
relationship what's the process like
here you
move yeah right yeah so if you okay yeah
I mean you have you have a boyfriend I
left out thank yeah yeah okay but like
how long are you in a
situationship until your boyfriend and
girlfriend
situationship listen we on a timeline
sir situationship cuz you're not about
to play no I'm talking talk about you
the average oh sit I ask you don't got
friends you don't they don't tell you
about their lives she's been in this
situationship for like five years yeah
that's terrible so I just I don't know I
really don't know wow I just can't get
it together what do you mean but he
doesn't want to commit right no he
doesn't it's it's him like he does the
same thing
sorry oh sorry um yeah like I it's like
a pattern from what I'm seen so like
they're together they're perfect they're
enjoying each other and then like after
2 months I don't want to commit anymore
and then they don't talk for 2 months
and then they start over again but who
do you think is the one that's
initiating that because generally women
are not going to sit there and ask a guy
to marry them I mean nowadays it's weird
but you guys aren't worth committing to
I'm going to be honest with you you guys
is a lot of people in general but in
Miami it's different because because we
have so many options that we don't just
want to stick to one well that's why I
said you move you leave Mi if you want
but you should you should to stick to
okay so there are no men in Miami that
want to start
family there's no men or women that want
to start family there's no men or women
it's like to risky okay okay but let's
go back to my question how long of a
situationship talking phase let's let me
ask the men how long of a situationship
talking phase are you going to do before
dating a chick me personally I don't I
don't do it I I've had four
relationships my whole life and I'm 35
so I'm very intentional when I date but
most guys I I see that they're not like
that and to be fair I just moved down
here from Maryland and the women in
Miami please don't come here guys
passport Bros all day long do not come
to Miami even the even the ones that
aren't from Miami end up just like the
girls from Miami I've seen it personally
yes just not all of the girls majority
majority majority majority listen your
lifestyle you go out all the time I I
see your stories Liv my life listen they
all end up the same you can bring a girl
from Texas to Miami give her five six
months I swear to God the amount of
options that she has over here she's
gone yeah she's gone yo yo I have girls
that come to my podcast we're here for
the weekend I see them after they leave
getting [__] that's terrible I'm
telling you it happens all the time I
get on them all the time that just goes
back to standards nobody in Miami has
standard because everyone that just well
the women have standards don't they cuz
they're not [__] the guy from
Publix way before I wa wait okay so so
let's go back to the question oh six
months situationship till relationship
one year a is like three months I would
say three to months but wouldn't that
just be the talking phase no okay no
okay okay how long from meeting to
relationship oh mate it but it depends
what your outcome is though because for
me personally I'm not you know I'm I'm
sort of different to to to what he's
saying I mean I'm not really looking for
something serious cuz I'm jaded so for
me I keep I keep the you know so I quite
like the the sort of why are you jaded
man because I've been in big cities too
long and I've seen I've seen how you
know all this stuff operates and so you
know I'm I'm kind of enjoying the
decline you know so I'm I keep the
talking phase going for as long as
possible because I don't necessarily
want to Define it you know you have you
you've been you've been in relationships
though I have been in relationships but
even my say my ex-girlfriends who I was
with for about I mean in total we were
together for 3 years but first at least
a year of that was what you would call a
situationship really serious situation
yeah very very was she like pushy about
it at all she she was a bit Yeah the re
but the reason I liked her was because
she was less pushy about it than some of
the others because you know when they
get pushy you know what I was trying to
explain the other day when they're
trying to when they're trying to force
it it turns you off and she was actually
she was sort of I agree she was letting
me be as well and so then slowly over
time we got closer together and then it
became and I realized you know I she was
great and I wanted to be with her so
what
happened um see I I see I see that I see
the sparkle in your eye a little bit
when you talk about her feel like you
you like yeah like she know she was the
one that got away I mean that's yeah
completely and since then I'm that's
that no no no get the violin can we call
her can we call her I don't think we
should call can we you should call her
maybe um I don't know I don't think I
can do it now but um no I I love married
what happened to her know now we're all
invested we
need no no no so listen so listen that
was the final nail in the coffin of my
sort of um relationships life really
because I you know I did really fall for
her I really loved her but in the end my
lifestyle the stuff that I wanted to do
was incompatible with what she wanted to
do the family stuff well she wanted to
yeah she wanted to move to Suburbia and
settle down and all that kind of thing
and obviously she was pushing for that
and I just felt that wasn't a direction
I was able to go in and I also knew
because she was getting to late 20s I
also knew it' be unfair for me to sort
of cuz you know to keep stringing it
along how old were you at the I was in
my 40s you know so so she was she was
she was younger than me but you know she
was coming up to her you know to 30s and
stuff she about to H the W well I mean
yeah yeah the wall let's be honest yeah
she was she you know she was obviously
she had a time limit in terms of what
she wanted to do and I thought if I keep
this going is going to be to her
detriment you know so but it was tough
and you know what's funny you still
looked out for her best interest when
you didn't have to well I did at the end
because but what happened we we split up
and there was we went back and forth a
little bit we split up and then you know
you know you split out for a bit then
you get back you know you meet up again
and things happen and stuff like that
and that was happening and then there
was an opportunity at the end I think we
could have fixed it again and I could
have stay with her for longer and I
chose not to do that and that was a
deliberate choice because I thought all
that's going to happen is going to be
the same cycle I'm going to be with her
again for another six months it's going
to be great and then this is going to
happen again do you know what I mean so
so to answer answer your question I say
6 months to a year uh real quick I'm
going to be honest I actually like when
men sit here and take advantage of women
in a sense here in Miami because I see
that these women hold on let me finish
because I see that these women take
advantage of normal men so when they go
to the top 10% I actually love seeing
them come back because I'm like you
deserve that you dirty bit you know what
I mean that's really how I feel to be
honest yeah I'm not so do you guys agree
6 months to a year of a talking fave
keep it going keep it keep it going as
long as you can year I say 3 to six 3 to
six that's a long
talking six no you're right you're right
you're right you're right three to six
what do you what do you what do you
think is the average what do what do you
guys think is the average for guys yeah
like just just on the terms again
because when you talk about talking
phase because I don't want to go dig all
this up again but I think of talking
phases more like you know you guys are
messaging and stuff like that before you
sleeping together okay so you are you
are sleeping together before you've
confirmed is full on relationship I
don't know probably the average about 3
months I would to months I think guys
usually keep it going as long as they
can but I'd say on average I say on
average they probably hit about like 8
to 10 months but I think they try to
keep it as because we don't have as many
options like they can move on and have
four guys right now replace us but
you're saying you think guys keep the
talking phase or this I think going
going as long as I think they try to
keep it going as long as possible Right
like if I had three girls that I was in
a talking stage with i' try to keep each
one of them as much as possible yeah as
long but I think I probably wouldn't
because jez that's exhausting yeah it is
but here's the thing because most guys
don't really get those options so so
when you say the average guy then would
try and lock the girl down quicker
because if he feels he hasn't got many
options he'd be like more keen to make
her his girlfriend it depends on the age
like I'm in my 30s I I'm more uh you
know I'm more likely to get settled now
than I was in my 20s and they 20s no I
don't think guys are ready to settle
down but I'm sort of like I say I mean
for me I've kind of come out the other
side so I'm a bit more like now I'm
trying to keep my options open at the
moment you know what I'm saying so did
you have a lot of options as you were
like younger um like funny enough I got
more as I got got into my 30s actually
and I think this is another conversation
but I think guys you know 20s you're
when you're a teenager is a guy you're
screwed you know [__] youve got no
value 20s 20s less you know and then you
get into your 30s and sudden you've got
a bit more value as a guy and you you
get more options so in my 30s I I I had
a lot of options around him he's he's
being right actually you know now that
I'm in my 30 I feel the same way when I
was in my 20s I thought I was doing good
but now that I'm in my 30s I'm like what
happened but I think what it is is women
just naturally like older men they do
they they like all the guys you probably
a bit more established you I'm not
disagreeing I like you probably you
probably I have more Inc like I feel
like I have what's the what's the
perfect age for you guys to date
for astrology it's four years older okay
you want four years older what about you
probably gu what it's supposed to be
I'll take a 30-year-old 30-year-old you
uh for me it was would be maybe 2 to
four years older than me two to four
five five five I would say 10 roughly
SM I like five years of older I'm not
I'm not against the I really don't care
about that I I think what about you guys
from what about you Colombian guys
though in Colombia would you say that
bigger age gaps are more more acceptable
yeah I mean and in our culture that our
parents actually tell us to date older
not to never date
yeah because what I've noticed from
traveling cuz I'm actually going to
Columbia next week I'm going to bogatar
which I've been there a few times before
um Good Luck yeah yeah if I live through
it I'll I'll listen You'll walk down
that street and anybody will grab your
hand I've been there I've been there
three times before it's okay where we
stay is not is is all right although we
went to clean your hand up thoroughly we
went to we actually went to Santa Fe as
well which is the dodgiest red light
area and we were okay there as well but
you know anyway I get it things happen
there but the point is what we've
noticed traveling is that some cultures
you know the age Gap thing is less of a
thing so Latin America it seems to be
less of a thing and also in Eastern
Europe so you go to Ukraine or you go to
Russia before the war you get these
bigger ageg Gap relationships I think is
in the west it's very you know looked
down upon you know particularly by you
know the whole L on decaprio think oh my
God I
believe Savage
yeah I say good for you you know and
that's very much a western yeah isn't it
that you shouldn't be doing that yeah
it's the it's the women it is the women
because because think about it right
because think about it like this right
like I want to date younger yeah and
that's frowned upon but they want to
date older and it's okay right like
there's no problem what want to no no no
no time out hold on and I would never
and by the way I would never look down
on a man like when I go to Brickle and I
see these millionaires with these hot
chicks these older men with hot chicks I
never look down on them like I don't I
don't look at him like oh he's a
predator oh my God I don't know I never
look at it like that I'm like good for
him he he's in his prime she's in her
prime yeah I don't I don't feel like
like I mean I don't know maybe this is
just me and not speaking for myself
maybe not I don't give a damn who you
date as long as you're not dating a a
whole child you know what I mean and
that's really the problem about what
about what about an 18-year-old girl
with a a 35y old guy I was going to ask
35-year-old I was with I think that
there's absolutely something wrong with
that why because she's a she's a child
at I'm sorry at 18 years old she can go
to jail years just because you're legal
does not mean that she get tried out in
the either which way they don't say oh
you're 18 you're still a baby they sing
your ass to prison okay they do 18 is
legal yeah I just don't really like I
went to college when I was 17 like I I I
feel like you know what you're doing
yeah right like this idea that like
you're like uh you're 17
sure what's the difference I mean I I
did I like 365
days like so what do you think about a a
35-year-old woman dating like a
20-year-old
gross but then that's that's again like
I don't know no I actually I why is that
it was a joke it it was to be funny
hilarious but but no I I mean I think
there's something unnatural about it
yeah I mean it seems like how I feel I'm
saying I think that's natural it seems
like more than natural order that an
older guy is going to date a younger
woman that that Dynamic seems more
natural to me I mean you know I'm in my
40s I've dated generally speaking I'm
dating girls in their in their in their
20s and sometimes early 30s that's
generally speaking and that's been the
case but it goes back it goes back to
what Eric was saying earlier um I feel
like us women CH like um what's it
called tag each other with that we're
like oh she's dating a a 45-year-old
like what dirty ass hole you know what I
mean like who the hell is saying that
like there's girls out here that be
saying that just because an 18-year-old
like she was saying is with a 3 like
she's a she smart girl right there but
when the man do it it's okay and it's
like we're building right now that gives
the women that right it's not always
okay though because if you're the older
guy then you get the criticism from like
the feminists or the other people
they're saying no you're being
manipulative you're being a predator and
all that if you're dating a
girl that is clearly doesn't like is IM
mhm it's clearly new to the world like
literally like you have to teach her
everything if you're dating someone
specifically because you feel like you
can control them better or mold them
better or I think that there's wrong but
that's what it is I don't think that's
what but that's no no I think that's
better
though you I'll give you I'll I'll even
I'll even I'll even I'll even take one
for the team I'll use myself as an
example I think at 21 right right when I
was 21 it's easier to mold into the guy
that you want like into his life why are
you mold I I think in any relationship
you are both going to mold yourself a
little bit because in marriage probably
a lot in marriage it's two become one
flesh and I think it's much easier when
people choose to do that younger okay
women especially okay but and I think
women were just more influenceable so
like right but that's there's 's a
danger in that because a lot of women
get pulled into really terrible
relationships very early on and then
have those bad
experiences and now they're used up they
let's ask why let's ask why yeah women
suck at picking and really we should a
18-year-old girl that's just come yeah
she's probably going to suck at picking
a woman that's 30 years old that's lived
life that knows people that's not going
to get fooled easily is not damaged I
don't call it damaged you know what I
call it I call it
is trash for you because you cannot
control it you don't like anything that
you're not going to want
to this is what I don't understand every
heartbreak you're a little more damage
thank you like this isn't me I hope you
don't think you're not trash like I'm a
man those rules don't apply to me you
were born trash what do you mean exactly
go see I was born trash literally okay
it it's like I mean you not everyone can
be the hottest thing since sliced bread
we all get a little damage yeah listen
and I I I 100% agree with that but at 18
years old what what exactly is wrong
with a man and I'm not and I don't want
I there's nothing wrong with it he's
doing there's nothing wrong with it as
long as it's being done with good in
intentions the the issue here is is that
there many of these men are not doing it
with good intentions because they're not
doing it for the reason because they
want to they want start women don't want
the men with good int thank
you as a 30y old woman I
do no but the problem is you didn't want
those men when you were at your best and
we never pick the nice guys when we are
at our best well you're making this
assumption you're making this assumption
that these older guys just want to
control and you know manipulate these
women it's not really because of that
it's because it's because basically men
find young women hot that's what it
comes down to it's not like oh I want to
be this predator
what are attracted to so there was data
right that showed the ages that people
are attracted to one another and for men
it remained about 23 so the guys are
getting older you know from the guy's 23
he likes 23 year old the guy gets to 45
he likes 23y old 60 23 year so that's
just a biolog fertility fertility
individual so but the but so his
intention might be well I just want to
you know kind of see this girl and go
out and party and we're going to have
sex a bit and whatever but a 23y old
girl is probably not going to want much
more than that either in Miami is she do
you know what I mean it's not like
there's all these innocent young 23y old
women in Miami who oh God I just want to
find a good man and this Rich this rich
guy took me on his yard and [__] me oh
no they'll say that but they don't
that's what they're looking for as well
right that's what women have been
programmed to do is to find a husband as
soon as possible well but they haven't
now surely have they that's not but
that's not true yeah it is whim okay do
we have wait wait wait wait guys guys
wait wait wait wait do we have more
choice or l choice in 2023 and has the
average age of first marriage gone up or
down I'm not I don't know the average
age of first marriage is 30 it used to
be like 21 22 so that's what I'm saying
it was programmed in us to get married
early that's what I'm saying no no I'm
I'm saying we were not programmed to do
that because if we were if we are
programmed to do that now then we would
do it but we do not oh cuz we don't have
to we're not putting the position before
the men had more power we had to find a
what do have more power now what I'm
saying is these 23y olds don't these 23
year olds don't don't want to get
married that's what I'm saying are you
saying that they're but you're saying
they're being programmed to but then but
yeah like back in the day women started
as soon as they were like 12 years old
they were already getting you're
saying I get what you're saying but
eventually
eventually wom women have this dream of
the white dress and the wedding I get
that but they also go through what R
calls their party years which is when
they're sort of 18 to I don't know 27 or
whatever when they want to go out and
BAS basically they want to run you know
have a great time run wild that's and so
if you're saying these older dudes like
you got Leonard DiCaprio who's dating
these 24 year olds and stuff it's not
like these women are these you know
naive young kind of things and they're
ad was so naive and they they're getting
they're getting what they want he's
getting what he wants I don't think in
most cases anyone's really manipulating
anybody it's just it's just you know
they they're coming together if you're
dealing with someone that is mature and
that is it's clear but that's not the
case a lot of the time a lot of the time
men are going for these naive girls that
really are just making terrible
decisions from wait who are they going
for who's who going for like these men
are who who are the men like I just want
to know who are the men and who are they
going whatever men that we're talking
about the particular men that are that
are that are only dating younger women
if they're only dating young we we we
talked about a survey earlier where I
said out of 5,000 men only 10% report
having more than one sexual partner in a
year she doesn't care about that to
detector test you don't know what I were
they okay okay okay again I I gave you
the reasons how we came to these
conclusions it's not just one study it's
multiple that were similar let's say
they're lying and it's 20% that's still
80% of men that are not [__] around
like that so why are we only talking
about the 10 20% there's very few men
that even have the options to manipulate
you yeah most men get some [__] and
they're like good enough I'll take it
100% okay so okay also well again these
are you're going to get a higher quality
of men even just being in this room is
going to be a higher quality of men
because the men at Tesco aren't going to
be at this PO oh sorry you guys don't
have Tesco here but the men at the men
at Walgreens are not going to be on this
podcast and then you know the garbage
collectors are not going to be here
either so my point is there's a very few
men that even can do that so why are we
pretending like most men going for
younger women are trying to manipulate
them they're not also another point is
here in Miami I think you can become a
bartender at the age of like 16 17 no 18
18 well I'm telling you here in Miami
you can become a bartender it's illegal
whatever whatever it is happening also
at 18 you can buy cigarettes right right
you can uh I I guess you can even buy a
weapon a gun right you can you can do
all this [__] at 18 you can have sex
with whoever you want whenever you want
but if you date an older guy oh my God
it's not I don't think listen I never
said there's anything wrong with younger
women dating older that's not the
message that I'm saying I'm saying there
there's if the intention is there talk
about manipulation if the intention if
the intention is
to date her to marry her to teach her to
mold her then fine have at it but if
your intention is not that then yeah is
a little creepy for men to go for
somebody younger that they have no
intention on like Lally because in that
case then just go for the the 24 year
old or the 25y old or the 30y old or the
whatever the [__] but like but the
18-year- old's hotter yeah that's fine
okay all right well then there's that's
that discipline thing there's that
discipline thing like what okay so I
just a fat person can drive past the
[__] McDonald's and decide I'm going
to [__] eat that [__] because it
tastes delici but it's still [__] up
but but it's like it's more but it's
more like so you're giving but a little
B it's a little bit different when it's
a little different when they're offering
it's like free food to a homeless man
these women are half naked out of high
school they're walking around nak women
you cannot expect women to have this
huge accountability for every single
[__] thing that they do when men will
not even have the own
accountability it sounds like you don't
want them to have any accountability
because you're saying that even a a
woman who's leg who who's legally of a
she has no accountability because she's
so easily manipulated by this elder dude
but probably I think that I I think that
if you meet somebody and you and and you
can pretty much tell if they're naive or
if they're smart enough to to make
proper decisions for themselves right so
it's a matter of you're a smart guy
you're intelligent when you have a
conversation with somebody you can tell
if they're pretty much if they're mature
or if they're not right so then you
should base your decision on that and
not I'm not going to you're going to
base your decision on if she hot or if
she's young enough and if that tight if
that ass is tight enough or whatever the
[__] you make up in your mind you're
never going to first think is this a kid
that I'm talking to what where is she
and the on the maturity no I'll tell
I'll tell you what men tend to be good
people so they do tend to think about
that women tend to be bad people yeah
yeah yeah men men tend to be better yeah
I mean I think there's there's a couple
of points here so firstly for me
personally I do tend to date more mid
20s to be honest I'm not really like you
know hanging around 18 year- olds as
such although you know of course no he
said mid2
then because that's he's that type of
let Troy finish guys let Troy finish so
you know so yeah that on that score I do
I do take your point but I mean having
said that you know I've also dated women
in their earlier 20s and so on and I
mean I think it's it's a little bit I
mean most of these women that I meet
they're they're not these incredibly
naive kind of stupid people you know
they're actually generally speaking
they're working they're doing their [__]
they got you know they're getting on
with this their life and they they they
they know what the [__] they're doing
you know cuz I wouldn't want to deal
with somebody who didn't but most of
them but I'm not talking about them I'm
talking about the ones that aren't she's
talking about I'm talking about the
girls that are obviously but but my
point is these these girls nowadays are
graduating high school with like ass
pictures on Instagram they look like
like these aren't these innocent 18 19
20 year
olds their yeah I do because I didn't do
that justed you were guided well no no I
I know I know no I know I know girls in
the exact same situation wait let me
finish I know chicks in the that were
raised the exact same way as I was and
did completely different choices it's
all down to what choices you make I'm
not into this excuses I was raised I
know women from single parent homes that
didn't do that I know women from two
parent homes that did I know rich and
poor women that made both decisions I
think attention seek women do more
things like that and that that's my
point so I'm saying that most women that
graduate high school or in college now
are not these innocent chicks that don't
know what they they are doing they they
typically want to be horse yeah no we I
what I'm saying what I think she's
saying what I think she's saying is that
there's older men there's older men that
literally only want to be with someone
from the ages of 18 to 23 just because
it is easy to manipulate and they aren't
jaded and they don't have opinion I
don't think it's because it's easy to
manipulate but there are men that do
that and what she's saying those men
that choose to do that and choose women
just based on that because of how old
they are that's what she's saying is
gross it's not gross for an older man to
want a younger woman that's very normal
but the ones that literally say I don't
want anyone over the age of 23 or I only
want this those that's where it's gross
and where you guys are kind of focusing
on the wrong things here like but that's
like me saying that women that want to
date High status men that make good
money are only doing it to manipulate
them like it it's well that that only
going to lead you
to let's be honest but the reason why
women do it is because it gives you a
chance at a better life right the same
reason why men do it with women we want
to go younger because we want to have
kids with a healthy beautiful young
woman it's not because we want to
manipulate you want to manipulate do you
think that if a woman went you know
started dating a man only solely because
he has money do you think that she's
going to live a fulfilled happy life no
she's not that's what I'm telling I I
think that that woman would have a
better chance us to do it all the
time
and and they were happier back then too
H do you know
that do you want an answer do you want
an answer I can give you the answer you
said how do we know that um and I would
say by one rate we could look at is
anti-depressants women on
anti-depressants and results you know we
have the
largest single childless women ever 70%
of women under 30 don't have kids
typically would we agree that kids make
women happy yes
no General would you would you agree
that marriages are better when people
stay together in general yes okay so and
we look at the outcomes from a 100 years
ago 200 years ago generally
antidepressants we're better yeah no I
mean go ahead no the anti-depressants
and the big Pharma that was all recently
and everyone guess what guess what yeah
and it's been rising because women are
getting wor but there's other things
that contribute to depression you know
that right it's not just not having kids
it's I'm sure famine I'm sure famine
it's the [__] that they put it's the
it's the [__] that they put in our
food well I know and so okay so then how
do we come to conclusions you look at
writings from the women at the time have
any of you even read any writing of a
woman from a 100 years ago no see what
about 200 years ago no no no no you know
what's so funny in the 1850s feminists
actually um the Mary wal I don't know
how to say her last name but wall
something basically said that we're
going to have a hard time convincing
women to work because they're so happy
this is from the feminists the
liberators but that was a different time
period like that was where the family
was really strong yes because women
didn't have the choice to
leave thank you yeah and then what
happened when they got the choice as
many options they did but they but right
and let me exp there's a reason why you
can't if when a person is happy and
they're content and everything is going
great why the [__] would so I want to I
want to I want to point something out
and I want this is kind of my problem
with modern mentality is your first gut
reaction this is really common Happy who
cares you thank you it's your life you
get one
life it's not about you thank you and
this is the thing and this is this is
the problem our grandmothers
great-grandmothers understood it wasn't
always about us and the kids are more
important than me I will
100% I will I will 100% give up
happiness for my children thank you
should love your wait wait you should
love your kids more than anybody in the
world unless they're gay unless they're
gay or unless
unless see and see this is like look
this that you're trying to divert from
the point you said you said we you're
you're changing you're moving the
goalpost we're talking about happiness
you said that it's about your happiness
I'm saying that it's not it's about
family and raising children that was the
first thing that you she said that too
happy but there was reasons for that
they women at that time didn't even have
bank accounts they couldn't
okay of course they because you were in
control it's fine and great when you're
in control when the man is in control
wait wait okay do you do you have any
idea the history of that no you don't
this is the CRA this crazy I know that
you don't because the reason the reason
actually there was female property
owners in the 1600s women absolutely
could have bank accounts they typically
didn't because because most people were
married 85% of people were married okay
and so typically the only way a woman
would have a bank account was if she
inherited money typically but there were
always the first female millionaire was
in the late 1800s how did she do that
without a bank account none of this this
is all re this is all this is all
Rewritten history because they want you
to think you're a victim it's literally
the the all of women's studies stuff was
implemented and and they literally
women couldn't have bank accounts unless
their husband signed for it my life is
perfectly F and you know what's happened
now women own all of the debt yes yes
everybody has a debt no no it's majority
Women Believe women they have a shopping
issues exactly and I'm saying there were
women that owned businesses there's
always been high IQ women that have done
really cool things in History Joan of AR
Cleopatra like I you can you can name
this stuff off but this idea that we
like didn't have any choice back then I
mean there was there was no there was
look it there was female opera singers
[__] up their husbands in divorce
court in the 1800s it just wasn't as
common MH like like this idea that and
this is the thing it's all propaganda
that you guys have been like taught
because all of the women's studies it
was implemented by The Rockefellers and
they implemented it in the early 1900s
and what they'll do is they'll say the
women of those time periods were
oppressed and they could not Poss you no
but this is no they weren't this is the
thing they were not they were not
oppressed they were they couldn't vote
they couldn't own land they couldn't
have but why but why couldn't they vote
this is the thing you guys have no idea
a man's world the man wrong wrong wrong
wrong wrong so because you don't know
and I know you don't know and the reason
is because it came with the
responsibility of being drafted the
military and there was more women that
were against women voting than were for
thank you all of the wives and mothers
came
together he watches my show you know all
of all of all of the wives and mothers
came together they were called the
anti-suffragists the suffragettes were
the women that wanted to vote they were
typically old spinster cat ladies the
anti-su and they and the anti-
suffragettes had posters that literally
depicted them as old spinster cat ladies
and they said this is going to be the
breakdown of the family guys don't do
this if you let women vote they're going
to spend too much they're going to go to
War World War I happened right after
World War II because all of the policies
everything now is passed for women all
of the media is catered to women because
we make 80% of consumer buying decisions
all of the policies are passed for women
because we're the majority of Voters
everything's catered to us but we don't
do the majority of the work and I don't
think that's fair that's why I don't
think women should vote because 45% of
men do a job that runs the
infrastructure most women don't do that
it's like 7% of women we live here why
would we not have a say in where we live
well because I don't I believe I don't
believe I don't believe in rights
without responsibilities so I think if
you're going to if you want the right to
do whatever you want in a house
shouldn't you pay the bills I pay the
bills in the house cor correct but we
have to look at this from a society
point of view if you're not helping
protect the society if you're not paying
taxes in the society if you do right but
I'm saying women atlaw if we took out
women that were in debt if we took out
women that aren't in the military it it
most women would be gone anyway if we
just said only net taxpayers could vote
and only women um that are in some sort
of infrastructure job that could vote
most women wouldn't vote anyway but
that's because most women are always
their main point in life is to find a a
husband and to get married and I don't
think that should be a no but I'm saying
that's not right so if that was true
then under 30 70% of women would not
have kids 45% of women so we have five
women here half of us will not have kids
half of us will be single and childless
for a lifetime out of the other two one
will divorce and one will stay married
Happy Days guys yeah yeah this is this
is the future so you're this idea that
women are so focused on a family and or
on a family is not true I think there's
two things going on here though I think
I think the indoctrination you're
talking about I whether it's
indoctrination I think women young girls
do dream about getting married I think
that's true but then I don't know what
happens but they hit
1819 but they do don't they I want to
dress you know but but but then
something happens they hit 1819 and
Sunny's like let's go to Cancun let's
party let's go to Miami and they want to
push it back then CU because you you
kind of want both The Best of Both
Worlds so yeah that you that is still
the dream but also I want to have my fun
while I'm young because you get to be 50
60 years old and you leave your husband
that you've been with for 40 years
because you didn't get to experience
life because you jumped into a marriage
and having kids immediately but 80% of M
of divorces are initiated by women
remember yes and it comes back to
happiness back in the day it was about
vows and it was about your duty now it's
all about happy I want to be happy this
is my life it's my life I only get one
life yeah but listen when I when my kids
were born I it wasn't about my happiness
anymore MH it was about my
responsibility MH that was it but your
kids don't live with you they live in
another state yeah but I'm still
providing for them like it's I moved
down here I'm yeah but but a man doesn't
have to be there every single day no
they don't have to be a present figure
no no this is where you guys get wrong a
man doesn't have to be present every
single day
no basically who is listen a man doesn't
have yes and that's her Duty that's why
she gets everything gets paid for you
want to talk about a man and a woman
being in a household and a women having
fathers in the household you're not in
the household and we've already talked
about hold on hold on you guys let him
guys let him finish yeah I left oh so so
you're a man that left yes well I left
why because you wanted more options you
wanted no I left cuz I wanted to come to
a new city no because you you said this
before I was already coming down here to
work with freshman F oh do you know my
life do you know my life guys guys I
came yo when I came to Miami it wasn't
for new options there's new options
where I was at too when I oh let me
finish let me finish when I came to
Miami it was yeah yeah I'm telling the
truth when I came to Miami it was to
work with fresh and fit okay it had
nothing to do with girls I didn't know
any girls down here MH now of course
when I came to Miami you know the the
girls were something I came with working
with fresh and fit that's all they do is
get girls at fresh and fit and that was
basically my job there so what I'm
saying is what back to your point a I
don't think a man has to be there every
single day now do I fly back every
single month and spend time with them
and make sure they're good and pay for
all their bills yes but I don't think I
have to be there every single day to be
a good father as a matter of fact me and
my daughter we write letters every
single day we talk every single day we
FaceTime every single day right and
obviously my my goal is eventually to
move back to Maryland but yes I don't
think a man has to be present every
single day are you still with the the
mother though you got split but you
didn't you didn't split with the mother
in order to move to Miami right no we
were already splitting yeah we were
already splitting but to be honest
because we were already splitting was
the reason why I said [__] it I'm just
going to go to my on your podcast you
said that you um wanted to be with other
women and she was not about it and that
is why you chose to leave because you
weren't she you wanted basically Reon
but you said that's why that was one of
the reason exactly so that's men wanting
variety men wanting different well men
are always going to want variety though
but a disciplined high value man will
not yeah well but it doesn't already
EST I'll tell you I'll tell you what I
had a very similar view to you when I
first like got into the space cuz my dad
my dad's super successful he never cheat
my dad's like literally an angel doesn't
drink no social media but what I
realized is we're actually in a very
time and the high value men of today are
not the high value men of yesterday the
men under 40 have so much more options
and Temptation that my dad just never
would have had because my dad my dad uh
wait wait let me finish chicaa all right
like so my my dad's generation like my
dad goes to work comes home you know I
mean he's just like a you'd have to meet
him but he's like a sounds really really
great really great dad and he actually
went to India all the time for like two
3 weeks at a time and I actually agree
second family over there yeah I'm
positive yeah yeah it's possible it's
possible that's what people say but that
it's not really his type I don't know
like um but anyways so but what you
realize is the the men of today they
have so much more Temptation they do
they have so so it's like why it's
broken down the family dynamic because
both sides but that's only that's high
value men are only 10% of men remember
only 10% of men can do this most women
are breaking up the family Dynamic and
you know because okay cuz think about it
if you're already settling for a guy
who's not even a high value man and then
he starts cheating on you and lying to
you okay what is what is settling like
for me settling is like um a woman who
like is with a man but like there's
women all the time they're like oh yeah
he he's a I don't really like the way he
talks to me I don't like the way he
treats me but he's got money she
settling cuz she's he's got money okay
that's what I mean right because when
you say you're settling for a high value
man a high value man is only 10% of men
yeah there's most of us most women are
not going to get uh you shouldn't even
bother talking to them because they're
not going to commit to you okay because
most women are average most people are
average so I I don't think there's any
world where you can settle for a high
value man I think he would be settling
for you no no not settling for a high
value man settling for a man just a
normal way well yeah and and I think you
know settling for money that's pretty
good deal for most of History I don't
think so most women now I'm not I'm not
saying that's what you should pick for I
actually I don't even Advocate that's
what you should pick for I think
character is much more important but but
but work ethic is part of that which
equates to resources that's why I say
that I'm okay with a man that doesn't
make as much money as me but as long as
he has a dream and focus and discipline
but means he needs to make money later
yeah I can I can help him make money
later you know but that's the that's the
this is but this is the problem you
can't change a guy you can help me you
can you can no but I'm sorry so a lot of
times women women have this inflated and
I I'll tell you I grew up around a lot
of guys that make that are very well off
all of my brothers make six figures plus
they're very very high like very wealthy
neighborhood right and I'll tell you
I'll tell you what those guys were going
to be successful with her without a
woman if a guy can't do it on his own
he's probably not going to do it there's
no build there's no you can help a guy
sure you can make his life easier but I
just don't see women I would say in most
in most cases women make the guy's life
more difficult to be honest because it
makes it more complicated you've got
less time you've got to you know You'
got to spend a lot of time with her
you're you're less focused on your
project R and like are there exceptions
to this rule yes but most of those men
were going to be successful anyway yeah
see my my ex the one I was with for 8
years he was 32 2 years old renting one
half of a how did you how did you make
money how do I like now how did you did
you make money oh real estate real
estate real so you and him did Real
Estate together yeah I actually got into
real estate first and then I brought him
into it and then we started doing it
together okay so what you would like buy
homes and flip them okay okay but it
sounds like you were the one kind of
leading this yeah yeah yeah okay so he
was right right so he was helping you no
no no I was helping him cuz I got him
into it right but but who owned the
properties we both did equally
partnership okay it it just sounds like
you were leading this thing he allowed
me to lead it which is which is f I'm
not saying that's bad but I'm saying but
I'm saying it was your career it really
wasn't his that's that's my point but I
helped him make money and he got into it
and it so it was a man that was 32 and
later in life got money because he was
with the right woman who supported him
that's what I'm saying so like you said
there are exceptions to the rule right
but they're not the rule yeah yeah yeah
so but it does happen with the right
woman well you had a very specific skill
set and it sounds like he's done well in
terms terms of you know what he's
learned from you in terms of the career
stuff um but as I say I mean my
experience hasn't been like that really
you know I I think a lot of the time the
guy needs to be focused on his his goals
and push forward with those and often
the woman can actually get detriment to
that yeah know in most cases I agree
with you for
sure yeah and also man um I guess the
only thing I'd like to say is that you
know for the women like her well you're
married actually so I don't know why you
agree with
her I agree with her because those are
my views as well you can be married
she'll be divorced just give her five
years that's what I'm saying no
offense Mar how old are you I'm 26 so oh
okay so like if most marri everyone but
you know what the funny if most
marriages in seven to 15 years why get
married at all why have kids at all if
most of them end that's that's that's
actually the conclusion that a lot of
men are actually the that's the
conclusion that I that's no exactly
you're right why so why bother why get
get married yeah well my point is the
stats yeah the stats are not in your on
your favor so even even saying she's
going to be divorced it's like well like
what you said you're on the only F wait
please don't get triggered please don't
get triggered wait just wait just wait I
know I know I just I see the anger
coming out I feel it but wait wait I'm
just going to tell you why I think this
because most marriages ended divorce
anyway if you why get married why Fus
your whole life Mar wait wait Jesus so
like even even you're on only fans I'm
like I can't imagine the marriage rates
are amazing on only fans so it's like
just statistically okay you're probably
going to be divorced yeah so just like I
said statistically most of us will not
have a happy ending so remember when I
said in the beginning of this I said the
reason why people get divorced is
because they have the I'm going to go
out and find someone else I don't have a
reason to leave the relationship that
I'm with I get treated well there's
respect there's partnership we have the
same views we have the same goals where
the there's trust where the hell else am
I going to find I already have so a
couple questions couple questions how
long have you been married 10 years I
honestly this is like a lot of a
disclosure for but 10 years yes okay so
that sounds amazing I really hope it
works out for you but I know a lot of
people that were happily married at 10
years 15 years and said all the same
things and then at 20 years 25 forever
is a long time that's all I'm saying so
I wish you will you know back to what
she said what's the point then because
you're advocating for family I'm telling
you my I I advocate for the same
thing the so what's okay what's sorry
repeat the question repeat what was the
question what what you said you're ad
you advocate for family correct well so
do I I have the same views as far as
that goes I have a caveat what's your
caveat we got to change the laws first
of what I men will not return to
marriage until we make it less risky for
them in family court so uh you could it
doesn't really matter what I say matter
even the laws doesn't matter because at
the end of the day a man's going to want
something different after 15 years of
being with the same woman he's going to
want something different so even if the
laws are different there's no no wrong
wrong because again okay wrong wrong
wrong no F wrong I'll tell you I'll tell
you why it's wrong men used to get
married after three months they that was
the average it takes a man three years
on average to marry a
it used to take them 3 months so men
will get married when the risks are
lower the value different though and no
this is this is this is all of history
and this is before a thousand years ago
they did arranged marriages so they like
and that's just terrible bet no it
wasn't it wasn't can I ask you a
question because we you know I think
that me and you are kind of aligned in
so if you're in a relationship where
there's trust and you feel like um you
know there's nothing that's going to
break you guys up
mhm would you um open your
relationship like say for like one day
one okay spontaneous night and you know
you're in Cancun you find a girl
whatever I would do I would if I'm in
control of the situation and it's
something and it's something that I want
to do but as far as like as long and you
can't control that situation it's not
for you it's for your man it's for us
we're [__] here both it's for your
and this is the problem this is the
problem the now he's getting now he's
getting the problem is that women want
get the problem is that women want to
say yes baby you can go ahead and have
that girl but I got to pick her I got to
talk to her I got to do this you can't
do this you can't kiss her I'm going to
show you something and this might change
your life this might might okay and or
you'll go on today I could give you so
much wisdom she change your life
forever okay there's a natural order of
the world okay God men
women child so like a doctor I know
terrible handwriting okay but but okay
and the problem is the relationships
really only work when men follow God the
women follow men the child follows the
woman that good that's solid but when
you try to control things you're saying
that you're equal to a man so now I'm
not really advocating for the open
relationships I I know I yeah okay but
but the point is when you try to control
things you're really going more towards
an egalitarian model and so
relationships don't work when women try
to control men um I don't this this was
saor
Mar's and I could and this is based off
of hundreds of years of History I don't
want to control my man I want my man to
Le me I want him to be strong but I'm
just saying in the in when when I'm
opening cuz think about it I'm not you
have to be the one to decide I'm not I'm
not the one going out searching for a
woman I'm a straight woman so if I'm
doing it it's something I'm doing for
him out of love so to make me feel
secure and make me feel to make it to
where we're both happy then I need to
have some sort of control in picking it
cuz I need to one I need to make sure
I'm attach to the but the the thing is
you you would want to wait wait wait you
would want to be with a guy that one I
wouldn't really recommend that situation
anyway but but but but you would want to
be with a guy that you would trust
enough to give up all control yes
relationships do not work unless you are
with the man that you can give up
control I will give up control in the
relationship but if we're bringing
someone in I need some sort of control
that the reason why I bring it up is
because a lot of men tend to wander
after a certain amount of years certain
amount of years that's so let's talk
about why they wander because
no that's not well partially but no so
so I I interview divorce lawyers I know
so much look at this I'm like a
genius I interview divorce lawyers and
that deal with a lot of infidelity and
do you know and this is coming from a
divorce lawyer so third party right and
do you know what the most common reason
that men cheat do you know why they
cheat why I know why tell me why women
don't want to have sex women will starve
men for sex in relationship period And
so once you know and I talk to divorce
lawyers that tell me stories of 2 years
3 years four years no sex what do they
expect the guy to do why are they even
together now most and then we go into
the infidelity stats most infidelity is
a onetime thing MH so why could we not
work out a onetime thing oh yeah no only
10% of men can cheat like that do that
yeah definitely my friend you can get
over infidelity you can work through
infidelity absolutely my my point onlyn
in my point only is one I wouldn't
recommend picking a guy that would do
that you know but nothing nothing
nothing no it's not this is just the
stats don't back you up but not not not
that actually get variety um but my
point is relationships don't work unless
you can relinquish control I think you
have control issues just from Reading
you yeah so in this play scenario
whatever it would only work if he picked
everything yeah no it's not you say
that the thing about variety because
most men can't get variety so it's kind
of want us to move point is that well
that's I have two points here I have my
first point is that yes most men can't
get variety anyways yeah um my SEC
actually three points my second point is
most cheating is a one-time thing yeah
and my third point is if you're going to
do a situation relationships do not work
unless you give up control and Hope
hopefully you would pick a man that
cares enough about you to put you in the
best situation possible I wouldn't
recommend that you I don't I don't say I
have question though if you give up all
control you basically turn into his
whatever he wants in life but he still
leaves you in 7 to 15 why do it in the
first place with
kids this now you got kids so let me let
me let me okay okay okay let me let me
let me let me let me let me let me let
me I'll tell you what happens if he
leaves you so okay okay no okay I'm
answering I'm answering your question
I'm answering your question okay so you
asked me what happens if the guy leaves
you too often we have been sold this lie
and it's typically from our mothers and
our grandmothers that's typically the
generation that was fed a ton of
propaganda saying that men will leave
you high and dry if you give up control
and you always need to have a backup
plan that's their experience no it's not
it's not
it was not it was not so in the' 60s and
the 70s that was a very heavy wave of
propaganda very heavy and women just
repeat things they really do no the
women that I hear from are people that
are living their
lives their exp okay so the stats do not
back that up women actually divorce more
women actually way way can you can you
listen before you you okay women have
always left more always even in the 1800
women always left more so this idea that
the men are going to leave you high and
dry it's the exception it's not the rule
so um
yeah I think that's false no it it's not
well I think that men would generally
stick around even if they cheer to
keeper right of course corre it's going
to be a lot easier but who stays in a
relationship you leave then for them to
be the ones to be like because then now
they assume all the responsibil it's not
Blas and then they lose that that the
the sex at home the one that that
partner that's always there they lose
that they don't want to lose that it's
until a woman finally gains respect for
herself and she's like I don't have to
deal with this I don't have to be in a
relationship I'll tell you what I see
more often I think women find things to
complain about and I see this not only
in relationships I also see it in
society women are typically the human
resources department women are typically
the ones if you see any protest it's
typically done by women women love to
complain and what a lot of people don't
realize is their horror stories from
their mothers and their grandmothers
were not true and all the stories
they've heard from their parents and
their moms is really um just propaganda
but on a smaller scale and I'll tell you
why I believe this because women men use
violence and women use social violence
and this is something we and this is why
you'll see all these me too cases this
is why you'll see all of this stuff in
society and most of the time women do
not ask their dad for their side of the
story and if they did they would get a
very different picture asked I asked my
dad I they asked remember I mean listen
the reality is that I asked my dad did
yeah and whether you the reality the
reality is that fathers are less likely
to talk bad about their mothers that's
the that's that's that's that's the
truth number one and also so men attack
each other with violence women attack
reputation that's how they do tell you
what my dad told me before he passed
away a lonely [__] man he apologized
to me he apologized to my mother he
literally sat there and went through
every horrible horrendous thing that he
did to hurt us as a family because he
wasn't there and this was something that
was same beliefs the man is the leader
the man this the man and that but he
also stepped out whenever he wanted to
he did whatever he wanted to and
ultimately it hurt his family okay so it
hurt his family because your mom was
complaining about it I'm sorry he my
mother was too afraid to complain about
anything wait did they stay married no
my well yes they did stay married but my
my mom came to the United States and he
was just back and forth from
Columbia she basically he left he left
my mom to raise us mhm by by what was he
what was provide wait wait wait wait
wait what was he what was he doing he
wasn't working he was working okay so
was your mom like staying was your mom
was your mom's okay so was your mom
staying at home with you guys no she was
also working okay so they both worked
and then he would go to okay and then
how did you know he cheated cheated yeah
you said he stepped out how did you know
did you not know that till his deathbed
or did you know before no no she
definitely told me but it was the truth
it wasn't was ly and this is another to
make your point I don't agree with her
there was no reason for my mom to tell
me that I was a child I don't I I don't
think that what she did was right and I
can say that to her face now right right
but yeah
but listen but I I knew who my father
was it's not like he was some you just
said he told you at his on his death bed
how did you know who he was he told you
when he was about to die he apologized
for those things when he was about to
die so I have a I have a question your
mom was perfect in all of this no
absolutely exactly but that's my but
neither know I know okay we can we can
say that normally what happens though
that's not normally what happens what
normally happens is the the women are
much more willing to talk about the sins
of the man than the man is to talk about
the sins of the women I don't know your
wait wait I don't know your personal
situation you could be an exception but
when you do a thousand interviews you
see patterns so what's the pattern that
women are doing that is wrong joining
the the relationships and marriages oh
okay yeah so I'll tell you what happened
so I'll give you I'll give you like a
timeline here 1920s we got the right to
vote so after that women had the most
power in society when it comes to
policies and women what they first did
was they expanded the definition of
things and this is also what the devil
does the devil confuses you I argue the
women most women have we all have the
devil in us a little
bit and and no women especially But but
so what they did was they really passed
a lot of policies that discriminated
against men in Family Court um even more
so so for example um how are all these
men getting convicted of rape right
because it used to be forced sex that
was the definition of rape sort of VI
violently for now yeah forced I mean
they had a I'm just I'm paraphrasing but
now it's sex without consent well what
does that mean it's subjective so women
then they passed more government
handouts free and we want to be on the
benefits and we had a bunch of single
mothers and benefits um and then there
was a bunch of policies passed to
appease the women that paid the women to
leave and what did we choose to do we
left I don't think it was paying them to
leave it was giving them other options
they wer Rel it absolutely does pay them
to leave because most alimony payments
are given to women child support is
given to women women absolutely
weaponize their children to get money oh
yeah all and they also take half of
men's assets because they were they
because they weren't earning and they
were sitting in the house doing
whatever that's not that's not true so
so most of the time it's wom have been
working no women have been working most
of the time no because they're raising
the children you can't ra children in
like like you someone has to be home
while she's sitting at home she's not
making money she's literally uh living
off whatever you're getting or whatever
you're giving to her so she deserves
money at the end of it like just because
like if she had kept a job and didn't
have she had kept a job and didn't have
kids and you guys chose to not have kids
she would have had money money to be
able to live on after if the
relationship ends the women most don't
any but but you got to spend time with
your
children the children that the want
usually right well the women want kids
too so let's like let's like my sister
my little sister let not she was married
no no I'm not I don't have kids um my
little sister she got she was in a
relationship she got married he wanted
kids and then as soon as the kids came
he didn't help with her and all she
could think was all she kept saying is
that did he did did he pay for the house
yes okay so why is she crying because he
wasn't there to help with the kids okay
but he was working that was not his role
yeah it was his role how that a man's
role in the house is to help with a
partner it's not a woman's a woman's
role isn't to take care of the and he
can take care of his kids as well that's
why homes now are
so um broken because women do not see
the importance of taking care of a home
and that's why now kids are just as
crazy as ever women are as crazy as ever
and Men you know they're crazy too
because nobody can seem the seem to see
the importance of taking care of a home
who's raising those kids those those the
social media sing single mother single
single moms and then like my mom's a
single mom and I mean she did she did
pretty okay but I mean I'm okay but just
like you the fact that you guys don't
see the issue or in a home you would
rather go to work you would rather party
you would rather do this then be home
and taking care of your kids if partying
has nothing to do with it it's I'm
talking about a majority I'm not talking
about you I'm talking about majority of
women would rather choose themselves
their happiness their career they are a
human being and they never know when
they're going to die they should choose
themselves over everything always it's
that's
called it's called being selfish when
you choose to when you choose to become
a mother and when you choose to become a
father yourself does not matter yourself
is my happiness my happiness is my kids
my family my home that's what it is you
guys are preaching not preaching you are
telling when women oh focus on yourself
body autonomy yada y yada and homes are
broken because of that because of that
programming if you focus on yourself
first you won't get into a broken home I
will never have a broken home let's go
back I'm going to I'm going to give you
some
information I think on the path you're
on and I I'm going to tell you it's
funny it's funny thing happens when you
interview so many people I can like see
everybody but I I meet you all like in
different bodies like I I've met someone
with your temperament your temperament
but I meet you guys all at different
stages of life so I'll interview one
girl that's kind of like you but 40 one
girl that's 60 so I kind of see what
happens and that mindset right there no
women it only works works this is the
family right and when women focus on
themselves they can't focus on the men
and it doesn't work it'll never work so
when you say focus on yourself for a
little while I think it should no
genuinely it's you know what's crazy you
can tell somebody you
can look I because you know I I never I
was Catholic I you know I'm just I'm
giving you the
information so yeah so you know so you
can either pick family or me but you you
can't right now I'm choosing me and
later in life I will
choose you know I'm not going to lie so
there's going to be one of us all right
so I'm I'm going to bet on everybody on
this table on your life
yes yes um I don't think you'll have
kids I don't think you want them yeah
and I actually don't think women like
you should be forced to have children I
really don't everyone's everyone says
everyone should have a family I think
some women should not
yeah no I think honestly but if you do
want one you actually seem you actually
seem like a nice person so I'm I'm going
to try to help you so if you do want one
you should try this model it works
better EV
ASAP there's no ASAP men are getting
men ASAP at 50 60 70 years old they're
still getting married they're still
having sex so then there is no time men
can have kids at 50 I can adopt at any
age I can save my eggs at any age and
have someone else I'm I'm going to easy
yeah I'm going to honest bro I don't
want kids I'm being honest I don't it's
almost as if you can tell somebody hey
if you do this this is going to happen
and they can come up with an excuse
selfish is bringing children into a
world where you're not ready when you're
a child yourself and you I'm not 35 I'm
29 no I'm not ready obviously if I'm
making you know what's you know what you
know what's funny I actually I see
nothing wrong with that because I think
it's actually worse for her to bring
kids in World actually iwe I swear to
God you selfish mothers ruin everything
saying nobody's saying to go out and
have kids if you're not ready what we're
saying is that because women are so
focused on themselves that homes are
being are destroyed like a good family
there's no such thing as that because of
women going out and saying focus on
yourself do whatever you want have sex
whatever you want and you got kids out
here listening to that and you guys do
not the the traumatic problem with that
you have 17 16 year old yeah it's just
it's now so now the marriage age is 30
that means in 10 20 years going to be 40
oh yeah Ireland it's 35 England it's 3
push it's going to push back saying if a
woman finds herself and has her own path
in life before she gets married she's
going to make a better choice in choos
her let me let me okay
okay okay so I have a well I won't lie
to you I I have a hard time taking this
advice Ser you're in the only fans yeah
yeah sorry um but no offense but the
worst part is and I'll probably end up
having the most longlasting relation I'm
sorry listen I'm you guys can Circle
back around a cple married and you're
pushing her agenda which makes no sense
you have kids and you're pushing her
agenda makes no sense because because I
can see that she clearly doesn't because
you're miserable with the with the LIF
she is she has she's married and she has
a kid she so hot she'll get miserable
once she gets
ugly okay anyways you're hot is what I
got from that thank you guys anyway
listen what what I'm agreeing with with
her is if she's saying she doesn't want
kids if she's saying she's not ready to
have kids then that's a responsible
adult is a responsible saying I don't
want I want to I want to actually go
back to you so you you said um that
women will like make better decisions
later what it can can I get one example
of a woman that took that path the life
um I I'm I'm just speaking from my
personal experience but and I'll tell
you the funny thing I'm going to tell
you one thing when you start studying
history you start realizing that nothing
is new and people of the same life paths
just repeated it over and over again and
I've seen your Life Path before look at
I'm like a
predictor um how many cats do I have
about
four girl I'm already you actually yeah
so so what what women do you know that
have like I'll I'll give you an example
Genie May right this is someone that I
can kind of think you guys know this
chick Genie no none of you really the
girl she just got a kid with gie oh yeah
yeah yeah this chick you know and she
thought oh I'm going to wait till 45 or
whatever to have a kid and then she
found her dream guy and she got married
and you know what happened she said she
had too many bad habits and anger issues
to change and then he and then he
divorced her ass which is very rare for
a
guy oh and by the way she was masculine
and she admitted it she said I was very
masculine and he didn't like that well
if you leave it for too long you get too
set in your ways that's the other
problem you know so you're making the
argument oh well you know you find
yourself and you build yourself up as a
woman and all that kind of stuff but the
reality is that that then you come at
the other side you're like actuallyy
[__] that you know your requirements get
higher because you know you built up so
much autonomy and you don't want to let
anyone else in so you know I just I am
not saying I hope that like these
choices I I hope I wish the best you
know I just you actually seem like you
you could be an okay mother if if you if
you get less crazy maybe but you know if
you want to ever take that path I'm
going
to the whenever when I start dating with
intent I will find the right guy and it
will be dating with intent no I'm not
dating with intent right now I'm not I'm
not no I'm just not I no I just want to
do my own thing after eight years I want
time to myself just like like you you
said you said you're J I'm not jaded I
am just Cho to take time and casually I
get it I get it I was 27 years old and
only had sex with three people do you
know how sad that
is
emage seual
experence I I get it I I get it I get
what you're saying but I think I think
people need to make a choice and I think
people don't make a choice enough in
this day and age because on the one hand
like you're saying you know we've got
all of this stuff being blasted out as
you go girl you know Instagram you know
do all this all this [__] cool stuff
go to the party don't you don't need no
man and then but then also you got this
competing you you perhaps haven't but
many women have this competing Drive
which is but actually I do kind of want
to get married I do want a family and
stuff like that and the problem is that
people then it's like you kind of got to
choose you know what I'm saying and
probably women have to choose younger
than they're actually doing currently
yeah that it's better for the body count
thing do you have any idea it's it's a
bit sad so here's the the body count
stats I'm going to show you guys I'm so
I'm so awesome with my my chart
nice uh yeah so these are the men okay
so once you've slept with um one man and
you get married to a virgin or whatever
80% chance you're happy two guys 50%
chance you're in happy marriage three
guys it's like roughly I can't remember
if it's 40 but let's just go there 30%
chance Four Guys 25% chance so after
five bodies you're pretty much you're OD
this is why when I say most of us will
not make it because most women are done
okay well what I'm saying is if marriage
if marriage ends in s to 10 7 to 15
years why even do it in the first place
why would a woman get married to be to
have a kid or two and be left in 7 to 10
years whether on your own valtion or the
man's Val why do it in okay I'll I'll
I'll give you one women have everything
to gain cuz a lot of women do it to take
men's moment
money but if you're a good person you
won't do that um I would say that
nothing worth having is going to come
without risk and if you live your life
in fear um especially cuz women don't
have as much to be afraid of the men
have actually real things i' have
opposite advice for
men but I would say for women it's like
um things can always go wrong you can
get your heart broke but people I you
know I feel like it's better to try than
to just give up um I I I honestly I I
want to be in love I'll probably be
married to um eventually but I just
don't I no I will be for sure I mean I
had a 8-year relationship how many
people do you know of our age that have
that that long of a relationship so so I
I'm going to tell you what so it's not
that you're not attractive it's not that
you could not be married but what I
don't see and the the one trait that I
again it's just from interviewing people
just my opinion I could be wrong the one
trait that I have a hard time that seems
seems to have a hard time staying
married as women without humility I
don't think you have a ton of humility
you can work on it I do I do have
humility I should I said I think you
said you were perfect no I'm talking
about that perfect in the I'm in the
relationship I never did the reason and
the reason the reason I don't see this
is because they typically cannot admit
when they do something wrong I didn't do
any wrong honestly if I had his phone
number I could you've been in a
relationship for 10 years have you ever
had to ad you were wrong all the time
yeah and would you wouldn't it it' be a
lot harder if you could never what like
what specifically like were you the
things that I said that I could improve
on I mean oh just that so you guys you
said earlier that you guys don't don't
do therapy and stuff like that cuz
they're CS we like and this is just
being truthful we have been doing
couples therapy ongoing for a long time
because we both have things that we can
improve on as people and
because no that's that that's called
that that's called having um being a
responsible adult again and because
absolutely 1,00% still together because
there was there was a time when when we
talked to each other it was not it was
just an argument and it's and you're
right women do find things to argue
about I am I am the human resource
person in my home for sure 1,00% I can
admit that but because I can admit these
things is why I'm positive that my
relationship is going to last because I
want it to not only does he want it to
but I want it to and I do believe in
Duty I do believe in being an only fans
model that does not make it listen okay
well maybe maybe maybe I'll be the
exception to the rule I don't know I'm
saying that there's a lot of times where
we both have to admit to each other hey
I [__] up and there's a lot of times
where I have to be like I'm sorry I I
overreacted like that was that was that
was dumb and there's a lot of times
where he does it you know what I mean he
probably does it way more than I do mhm
you know what I mean like but that's
just that's just the way that it is you
do have to take it even even the only
offense but the only fans model even
even the raggedy ass only fans model me
and my ex didn't
so my ex and I we didn't really fight
ever that's why I'm saying to say what I
did wrong because we didn't really fight
we were really best friends okay I'm
going to I'm going to tell you what a
lot of times women in your position the
men feel like they can't tell
them I mean but look the thing is the
thing is with with with with all due
respect you seem like a lovely woman
you're very attractive you're you know
you got a good heart but you you you
like they said you are quite combative
yes and that is maybe that that that
that could be that that well that could
be a flaw because if I if I was dealing
well you're quite sort of I don't know
man you're quite sort of opinionated
you're quite sort of brusk you're quite
sort of this is what I think this is
what I think and to be honest you know
for me personally being assertive is a
being assertive she gets kick out well
men want women to be easy to deal with
in all ways I'm a whole person right we
want you to be tender we want I think
men want women I think men want women to
be feminine and they want women to be
very feminine and they want women to be
and and ultimately for a relationship
you want somebody who's very easy to be
with May and maybe you were very easy to
be with in i' I've had people tell me
men that I've been with and friends that
I bring them peace like I literally had
a guy get in the car as soon as I got in
the car he's like he's like as soon as
you get like just feel the vibe he
wanted the [__] he wanted the [__] oh as
soon as
you okay okay so so you know you could
either take this or leave it she won't
take it I just look it you could take it
or leave it this is just my two cents if
you want to be married someday from my
research you know this is what we expect
I was going to do that yeah here can I
take a picture of that yeah yeah yeah
yeah some people would argue government
goes in there but that's anti
yeah so Pearl do you feel like you will
be married at some point I do feel like
I'll be married at some point okay um I
probably should have started earlier
hindsight 2020 but yeah I do think I'll
get married okay you feel like your your
pool of men that are going to be good
for you is going to is getting smaller
and smaller because you're getting older
so well um is my pool of men getting
smaller and smaller probably yeah so
yeah I would say I probably had more
options five years ago everyone looks
hotter younger yeah yeah so one question
for you girl which one of these ladies
has a higher chance of being happier
long term her or her she's already happy
long term or I all of us yeah well no
cuz you guys are defin you definitely
def you you ladies definitely have a
higher rest you definitely are going to
be married divorce with multiple kids
and you're not going to have many very
many skill set and you're not going to
have much to do in your life you're
always going to be looking for someone
else to take care of you and then you're
going to find once you have that first
guy leave you with kids M trying to find
other guys to take care of you and your
kids that's what's going to happen for
you this is why the guy this is why this
is why the guy went from women to men
I'll tell you what I if I had to I'll
tell you what I think you know this is
just my opinion you know if I had to
place bets dies Alone um Everybody Dies
along literally yeah I don't disagree
with I would
say yeah
yeah know what she saying I think I'll
get married I'd say it's 50/50 if I get
divorced I hope not but you know um I to
bet you guys said your body counts so
statistically you're
done she might make I'd say she's got
the best chance but she how old are you
you're 20 I'd say I'd say you'll divorce
at 37 you see Paul she's she's young
Paul she's young and untainted so you're
34 yeah you got married at 2034 go ahead
sorry no I didn't say nothing he was
saying you're Ted so you've still got a
chance to take I think they'll both get
married though I that's what I would
predict surprising in Miami I guessed
this many that's what it's rare these
girls in Miami are not really on that
kind of or long-term Rel they might not
get married actually it might just be
long-term relation it's we're in a
post-marriage world so anyways thank you
guys for staying so long this was I you
guys are Troopers you guys can I ask two
girls a quick question is it true that
Colombian girls are the most Unfaithful
in the
[Music]
world I I I I
think I think I think Cubans might give
them a run for say really okay listen us
Colombians we're also raised with God
right we it is true we we're raised I
don't know about God but we're
definitely raised to be like very into
the man we're with like if we decide
it's you it's you forever that's C CU
man decides but okay okay but what I'm
saying is that it's it's very hard for a
Colombian woman to leave a situation
that they're happy hard it's just not
but to [__] around yeah huh is it half
her to [__] around behind his back
probably not but I don't think it's like
that with anybody I don't think that's a
Colombian thing I think that's like no
I've heard that I've heard that colan
can't believe I think that men make up a
decision of what they want but you guys
Al so I another thing that you also have
to know in Colombia there's it's percu
and like it's like a open air brothel
over there like literally you can get
sex on the street so [__] easy like
it literally like if bring forward it's
literally it's literally like going to
McDonald's and ordering french fries
over there like it's that simple guys if
you want to join us in columia next week
family is also aware of that away from
it or they push oh yeah Troy has some
content coming out on the network he's
going to be doing traveling um traveling
interviews absolutely so what I'm going
to be doing is actually doing some
interviews in Columbia next week so
we're going to talk to some Colombian
girls and get their opinions on the
street but listen don't get it
twisted these women are not like they're
they're not all [__] and they're just
like no like a lot of them have ve like
extremely high like what you guys call
delusional like I'm talking about we'll
sit there
and pretend to be perfect and then turn
on you with the quick no but that that
was the point I'm making because so my
friend who travels a lot he has said
about Colombia in particular that the
women you know they can seem perfect
they can seem so nice on the surface but
you know and infidelity happens you know
they'll bite you for sure yeah they'll
bite for sure so whenever you guys are
like oh passport Bros okay [__] around
and find out you going to be over there
pissed off that you married a a you got
to be the STD rates reflect that there
that's what I always they always want to
say like where are the women the
[__] I'm like just look up STD I
think South Africa and Brazil are the
number one Brazil they're top I Brazil's
top 10 I don't remember where but I know
I'm pretty sure South Africa is number
one but you know why don't why don't we
go around and say any final thoughts you
know and then where people can find you
starting with Troy and then go around
okay Troy Frances thanks for having me P
it's been a great show um you can find
me on YouTube at real Troy Francis and
also on Instagram and Twitter um if
anybody does want to come to Columbia
and test out this theory about where the
Colombian girls are I don't know when
this is going out but we're doing a boot
camp there 19th to 22nd of October so if
you're interested in coming along and
joining us and learning about dating and
social skills in Columbia in bitar drop
me an email Troy at real try francis.com
cool thank
you um as always I love hearing other
people opinions I love seeing where
other people heads um are at I'm
actually a huge fan fan of pearl can't
even believe I'm sitting at this table
um you can find me on Instagram Ashley
dhanore so yeah okay thank you very much
um you guys can find me at Rebecca J
live on Instagram um I guess oh
definitely only fans link is in my bio C
huh $2 shut up okay um anyways at least
five right Li live go ahead go to the
link in my bi and find out put it on
your story too let everybody know um
yeah Live and Let Live man that's it
Live and Let Live Live and Let Live
stupider words have never
been listen you're still talking so
that's Up For Debate um you can find me
on IG at Christy love period 13 um A
Pet's home away from homecore and
Christy love designs wait so do you help
find Foster
oh my God bro have a cat that I I do
everything I need to get listen listen
don't do that the more cat she gets the
lower her chances are finding a home
okay uh I want to thank pro thank you so
much for having all of us I think uh we
all know each other here which is pretty
crazy um you can find me at Eric
unfiltered on Instagram and then check
out the podcast too unfiltered podcast
actually all of these ladies have been
on this on our podcast so shout out to
you guys and thanks again Pro appreciate
it
um you can find me on Instagram at I am
fny L and also an unfiltered podcast as
well thank you guys all for coming this
thank you for your patience I know this
is a long one yeah um all right guys
make sure you like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel let me know
who on the panel's gonna die
alone who's gonna get who's gonna who's
gonna wait I don't know Pearl I think it
might be
you surely surely I'm going to die on
Pearl
everybody's going to die alone that's
I'm tell you everyone's going to die
going to die before Fade Out I love it
yeah yeah someone's got to do it right
like the video subscribe we'll talk to
you next time